at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
what's up you guys hey James [__]
with me I'm [__] with you I'm always
[__] with you that's just how that's
just how I roll yeah that's just how I
roll I came over here it says I'm
getting this video because you never
know what kind of video you're going to
be in because I was trying to get into
the next door yeah I know man it might
be next door in some kind of gay video
and she goes you'd love it
I'm like oh yeah like don't even
complain don't even complain yeah
uh yeah so
um as everyone is pointing out yes R.I.P
Tina Turner died today she was what 82
83 something like that before like hang
out with David Bowie now
yeah they're all in heaven together I
mean I don't believe in heaven but you
know what I mean it's like that maybe
there's somewhere they're in the pluroma
someplace they're in the Paloma yeah
like being cool and hanging out together
with Vincent Price it was you know the
subject of uh tonight's show
Vincent Price another guy that lived a
very very full life and I feel like
people that only know him from his
horror movies and don't get me wrong I
love his [__] horror movies but it's
like holy [__] the dude he's like the
epitome when I think about you know how
people say it's like oh you know um you
know a life well lived or man that dude
like lived the best life or whatever
Vincent Price is that guy he's that guy
I mean he just
I don't know he's he's a [__] Legend
man and it's like and he's and he did so
much other stuff
other than just being an actor yeah and
the cool thing about him is that
literally I watched a bunch of
documentaries about him and stuff like
that they can't find a single [__]
person that will say anything bad about
him everyone said he was just a
delightful human being at all times
I even watched Ian remember that show
that they used to have I don't remember
what channel it was on but it's called
Mysteries and Scandals with that AJ
benza dude uh no and uh yeah so some of
you guys might remember
and they had one about Vincent Price and
it's on YouTube and I'm like what kind
of Mysteries and Scandals could there be
about Vincent Price I never heard
anything bad about him and it's like so
I was like so I gotta watch it so I
watched it and it's like the Mysteries
and Scandals they had in there I was
like kind of a reach kind of weird I
said so that just goes to tell you right
there that they really couldn't find
anything like sorted or anything like
that about him it's like everyone was
just like nope he was just awesome so
Vincent Price is really not even like a
Gen X thing I I even I don't even think
if you because a lot of Our Generation
know who he is but don't know much about
him personally it's just some dude you
saw in a horror movie I don't even think
a lot of the Boomer even Boomers I think
it's like pre-boomer wouldn't it Vincent
Price is one of those guys that
transcends Generations yeah because he
worked
steadily in movies TV radio voice over
work everything like that from the 30s
up and almost up until he died in the
90s
um he was always working yeah and he and
it seems like he got rediscovered by
each new generation like so it almost
seems like and like I said we've talked
about this before where horror is kind
of a genre where like even if this
shit's old like you know horror fans are
going to be like all about it so I kind
of feel like maybe that helps I do get
this sense and a lot of actors have this
because we talked about this when we did
the show about uh Christopher Lee and
Peter Cushing is that you know when
you're an actor particularly when you're
kind of like classically trained or
you're a theater actor like you know
Vincent Price was
then you know you kind of get Typecast
and he got Typecast in horror movies I
don't think he really complained about
it over much but you could see that you
know he wanted to do other things like
not just horror movies as much as he
loved doing horror movies and playing
villains and stuff like that because
that was kind of his thing but
um you do get kind of limited but on the
other hand
had he done just other kinds of movies
and not horror movies I'm not sure he
would I'm you know he'd still be
remembered obviously because he's a
great actor but I think if you're in
horror movies it just gives you that leg
up you know what I mean because horror
movies like I said kind of transcend
generation and each new generation like
discovers the classics all over again
all I knew of him is that he was a dude
you saw in horror movies I didn't really
know much about the guy but uh turns out
that no there's a lot a lot more to him
you know I mean he wasn't just an actor
dude came from money too he did yeah and
uh was real popular he was evidently
like [__] like like Jenny said
everybody liked him he was just a cool
dude and he did a bunch of stuff Jenny's
collected all the all the details about
him all kind of fascinating stuff about
him about his life you're right I mean
uh probably not too many American actors
are like this guy this guy is almost
kind of like he would strike me like
some more similar to the British actor
kind of like Peter Cushing or [__]
old yeah he could definitely hang with
those yeah you know what was the other
guy uh Christopher Lee Christopher Lee
kind of like that you know
or um you know you just
guess you could say it was kind of a
kind of a scene stir too you know yeah
um almost kind of like a
what was that guy's name [__] that
doesn't matter you can go I was just
going to make an analogy it's kind of
like the actor version of [__] uh
um uh man describe him oh blue eyes
singer Frank Sinatra he's kind of like
an actor version of synopsis yeah
Vincent Price yeah like very
um Urbane yeah I think is the best word
and Tammy said Elegance he was very
elegant and the thing about it that's
funny it's like I was reading some of
the comments like underneath some of the
documentaries about them that are on
YouTube and it seems like a lot of
people particularly younger people like
they had seen Vincent Price like in
movies and stuff they're like oh my God
I love and surprise and all this other
kind of stuff but a lot of them thought
he was British yeah I'm like no he's not
not only is he American he's Midwestern
he's from St Louis Missouri Well he kind
of had kind of a gravitas to him so he
kind of came across like he was a
British actor yeah yeah and he did study
and uh you know he did like do some uh
stage work in London so the funny thing
about him is that he could be silly too
and he could be silly really yeah
yeah he could be silly but he could also
be silly in a horror movie and just play
the [__] really straight and it would
kind of be scary and silly at the same
time
um
he um he was just he had his own little
character he was you know
he was a phenomenon yeah and like I said
not too many actors particularly ones
that started in the 1930s
um are as recognizable like I said you
can go up to like a teenager and they
[__] know who Vincent Price is or you
can go up to like a super old person and
they know who've been surprises was kind
of forgotten about price though is uh
most people remember price middle aged
and old when he was playing villains
[__] people people forgotten how good
looking he was when he was looking young
man what a good looking [__]
yeah I mean he was good looking when he
was old too yeah he just got more
Sinister kind of looking when he was
young he looked like a real tall
better looking version of Marlon Brando
yeah better than Brando yeah yeah I
thought he was better looking than
Brandon went back in the day I like
Brando though Brandon yeah there's a
toughness to him you know sometimes at
least he seemed tough he wouldn't you
know and he did a lot of great movies
man you know [__] Apocalypse Now and
uh you know [__] wild one
Mr 88 said he had one of the two or
three most recognizable voices ever yeah
and that's why he did so much I mean he
even did um he doesn't Voice for like
the Great Mouse Detective that uh
animated film that didn't even
did the voiceover for Michael Jackson's
Thriller Thriller yeah he sang on uh
Alice Cooper he did some stuff with
Alice Cooper I think he works with uh
Deep Purple yeah so he did like all kind
of stuff he was just he just seemed like
he was so just restlessly creative and
he just like always have and you know he
just seemed to have this kind of
just Joy he just really wanted to like
live life to the fullest you know what I
mean and everybody that I listened to
that talked about him said that about
him yeah that it's like he just loved
life he was doing [__] experimental
horror movies so they were mixing like
British style Hammer horror flicks with
mixed with like 60 psychedelics and
horror with a doctor the abdominal
abominable Dr fives that's her phoebs
that we call it it's Vibes fives yeah uh
he was [__] great he was great in
that and that was that we saw that it
was about a year ago wasn't it well um
it might have been two years ago because
it was when Sophie was here but at the
old house so it was probably like two
years ago yeah it was just this [__]
weird psychedelic 60s horror flick real
colorful
kind of LSD inspired it seemed like it
dude running around killing people like
a serial killer and that was like one of
his favorite roles I think yeah it's
kind of like an evil version of Batman
you know he was uh he played a villain
on The Batman series too like the the
cheesy one with Adam West he played uh
Egghead what Egghead I don't I didn't
see that yeah where he had like this
kind of big bald and he kept making like
egg related puns all the time it's
pretty great I wouldn't mind watching
that old series I haven't seen it in a
long time
yeah I liked it when I was a kid I'd
probably still like it it's probably
funny
it probably is yeah I heard that it was
like a hit show adults were watching
yeah yeah it was It was supposed to be
funny you know just a goofy show and
people yeah it's campy yeah
Sabrina said didn't he also make his own
cookbook yeah he actually um him and his
second wife uh Mary Grant uh Mary
Vincent she um they they did a bunch of
cookbooks actually and Vincent Price
actually had in the UK I don't know if I
don't think they ever showed it over
here but he had like a six episode like
cooking miniseries that was called
cooking price wise and he had
um a book that went with that but yeah
the I think the book
um the big main book that they did which
like a treasury of American recipes or
something like I said they did more than
one it went out of print for a while but
I think um that it got reprinted in 2015
like they started putting it back out
again and that was mostly because of his
daughter Victoria who kind of like
oversees his
um you know all of his re-releases of
his movies and his books and stuff like
that she like you know curates his
legacy uh essentially is what she does
yeah and uh she seems like a lovely
person also when I was a kid I would
sometimes confuse Vincent Price with Max
von Sato you know what I mean I gotta
get him confused sometimes they look to
like to be
they do a little bit I guess when I was
a kid I thought they were I'd get him
confused yeah yeah
uh subjective perspective says uh uh
Collective sorry I missed that I highly
recommend mask of the Red Death you know
if I had to pick my favorite Vincent
Price movie that would probably be it
but it's kind of hard because he was in
so many and I haven't seen them all like
I've probably seen
90 of the horror movies he's been in but
you know as many of you are pointing out
he was in like a [__] ton of others he
didn't really start getting into horror
movies until like well he was in one in
um and he was in like the sequel to The
Invisible Man so he was in that but he
didn't really like take off as like a
horror star until House of Wax which was
1953. so prior to that he'd kind of been
he's like a character actor he he mostly
did like period pieces noir films that
type of stuff dramas he did some
comedies and stuff like that as well um
because he was actually very funny and
actually everybody that knew him said
that he was like just a funny dude just
like Offset you know what I mean I gotta
say I think my favorite movie with him
in it was last man on Earth
yeah that's a good one I mean that's
what I mean it's like so hard to pick
like I said if you put a gun in my head
and tell me you have to pick your
favorite Benson price movie it would
probably be mask of the Red Death but
there's so many there was some good
Edgar Allan Poe once he was in remember
when he's uh yeah I think he was I think
it was with Peter Laurie and they're
doing magic fights yeah that was the
Raven the race car laugh was in that
team Boris Karloff was in it too yeah it
was a good one
he was in pitting the pendulum yeah
he was in Tomb of Ligia too I think yeah
he did a bunch of the Roger Corman ones
which I like I said those are my
favorites I love all those Roger Corman
like Pro adaptations
they're just it's amazing to me that
they were filmed for like no money but
they're still just these beautiful
they're Classics yeah they're just like
these classic films it's so [__]
great yeah some uh people are talking
about Laura which I've actually been
wanting to see you know what I watched
last night so here's what I did last
night I was like well I want to watch a
Vincent Price movie I was like it could
either be one that I haven't seen before
because there's a lot of those or you
know one that I've seen but not for a
really long time it's you know in
preparation for the show so I go on
Amazon Prime and they had a bunch that
you know that we just covered like not
too loud like they had theater of blood
and stuff like that which I think we
just reviewed sometime this year so they
had a bunch of those and I was like okay
well they had and then I thought they
had pitting the pendulum and the Raven
and I was like ooh maybe I can watch
both of those but it said they had them
but then I clicked on them and they
didn't have them so they said
unavailable I was like all right what
the [__] is that all about however they
did have one that I had heard mentioned
that I'd never seen before one of his
early films and it's called Shock I
think it's from 1946. it's not a horror
horror movie it's more like a thriller
um but man I got really into it
um and I had never seen it before and I
feel like it's one that a lot of people
don't bring up and it's a it's a role
where he's
um I mean he essentially plays this dude
who
kills his wife
in their hotel apartment or whatever and
this other woman who's staying in the
hotel like sees it like from across the
way like from her window and the girl
you know the woman goes into shock and
she you know and then it turns out that
like the psychiatrist that comes to tend
to her because of her shock-based
Amnesia is Vincent Price who killed his
wife so it's just like this whole thing
so he's like trying to maybe make her
forget what she saw and like the husband
is sitting there going what is this kind
of treatment that you're doing and he's
like yeah we're gonna do insulin shock
we're gonna do it and then just like
maybe we should kill her too and all
this other kind of [__] because he's
also like banging the nurse or whatever
which is one of the things that made him
kill the wife so it's great it's like
he's really really good in it like as a
villain but he's not like it's pretty
subdued you know what I mean it's not
like real campy or anything like that
because it's like one of his earlier
roles so he's like evil in it but like
he also toward the end gets like starts
to regret you know what I mean so he's
not just like a cackling villain he's
just kind of like he does all this stuff
and then he's like oh [__] maybe I
shouldn't have done that you know what I
mean so he's like a little bit reluctant
um thank you so much subjective
perspective Collective uh love this
topic I'm trying to own every price film
211 I believe damn hashtag goals he was
in a lot and not only that but I think
he made over 2 000 television
appearances
um and that doesn't count like all his
voice over work and all the stuff he did
for radio and all that kind of stuff I
mean the dude and like I was you know
there's extensive interviews with his
daughter who also um wrote a biography
of him
that came out um several years ago and
she's like he was basically always
working and he didn't he didn't seem to
have any distinction between it's like
well that's why he was in like kind of
these quote unquote B movies which you
know it seems that's a little dismissive
phrase to use but that's the phrase that
they would have used back then and I
think a lot of people would have said oh
you know an actor of your caliber like
what are you doing in these like cheapy
you know American International pictures
and all that kind of stuff but he just
really liked to work you know what I
mean he did a movie yeah I mean he
basically just said the only thing that
makes him think that like oh my career
is on a downturn is if I'm like not
working yeah so he would and he would
like later on he would be in commercials
he was in like print ads he was on The
Muppets like everybody saw the that was
great I still remember I can't believe
he actually didn't do the voices and the
voiceovers in in uh Disney's Haunted
Mansion he did you know what he did um
for the Paris one okay like he did the
voiceover for that but yeah but they
didn't use it for long but because then
they decided oh where they're gonna go
with um one that's all in French because
he did it all in English okay yeah um
but they kept his laugh so I think if
you still go to the Haunted Mansion in
Paris like they still have like Vincent
prices because it follows it should have
been visit price
yeah doing the voice over to the to the
ride
even though the dude that does it is
really good I know I love that but it's
been surprised every time I hear that
guy's voice because he did a lot of
voiceover work too that guy I can't
remember what his name is but he did a
lot of uh voiceover work too and it's
like every time I hear it it's like I
always hear the [__] automation [__]
yeah so great uh yeah Mr 80 it said
Laura is the most acclaimed film I can
think of that he was in yeah that's
right that's yeah he got like a lot of
um that's probably I don't know wanna I
don't know if I'd say if that was his
breakout role he seemed to have like a
lot of those
um and then uh yeah Mr 88 said I wonder
how many radio dramas he was in I would
guess hundreds yeah like a [__] ton I
don't even know if anybody like I'm sure
somebody has counted but
um oh and mango recommends Dragon Wick
which I actually I was gonna watch that
one again because I saw that when I was
probably like a teenager
and I remember really liking it but I
haven't even seen it since then so I was
gonna watch that but then I found shock
instead and I said oh I haven't seen
this one and I had just like read
something about it so I watched that man
instead and I ended up really really
liking that one even though I think that
one was
fairly low budget but like I said it was
you know like if more like a thriller
you know it's like a murder mystery
murder type of thing
um yeah they're talking about Thriller
well yeah I heard I don't know if this
is true or not I heard that he didn't
get paid for that I don't know if he
just didn't get paid or if they just
paid him like a paltry sum and then the
the album was like the biggest selling
album of ever and then they didn't like
cut him off a piece even though he's
like the best part about it doesn't make
sense that he wasn't paid
that's what I mean so yeah I didn't
really know if that was true or not I
just heard that somewhere and I was just
kind of like I don't know that doesn't
sound like yes it doesn't strike me as a
Michael Jackson fan for the time either
just like he'd do for free
I'm sure it's probably just a rumor yeah
maybe he probably got a regular paycheck
for what he considered to be a regular
paycheck for it yeah maybe not have been
much
maybe not just what you're talking about
how would he know that was going to be a
big hit well yeah I think that's kind of
what the implication was was that they
just gave him it's like hey we'll give
you x amount of dollars for doing this
voiceover and then and he's like oh in a
music video whatever okay well like I
said he was rolling like he worked with
Alice Cooper and deep purple and stuff
like that so he was he was kind of like
you know hip and cool and like up on the
you know what I mean he wasn't like a
regular old man that was like are these
kids today
you'll see it he saved he seemed like he
was really kind of uh far ahead of the
curve which like I said I think that's
why he keeps appealing to each new
generation because he just doesn't seem
like he doesn't seem to belong to any
particular era really yeah you know what
I mean I'll tell you one thing about
that dude he was tall
much taller you think it was probably a
six six I think he was six four six four
[__] huge dull dull skinny dude yeah
he's a big [__] yeah
you know but he was he wasn't in a
bodybuilder or anything but uh he wasn't
a bean pole either a big dude
yeah I was watching that movie shock
last night and there's one scene where
he like walks across the house like to
answer the door and I'm just like God
he's a big [__] I was like well I knew
how tall he was but it's like he looked
really tall in that [__] scene
it's just like [__] which would have
made him a lot taller than
um dude to play Frankenstein
wasn't six four no I don't even think
Boris Carla for six foot
I don't remember how tall Boris Karloff
was
I mean obviously he looks big as
Frankenstein's monster but that's
because they put the big shoes and yeah
big fake uh shoulder pads on
Anna I saw like a little uh tribute to
Vincent Price like somebody did on
YouTube and at the very beginning of it
they had a clip from the Red Skelton
show that had Vincent Price and Boris
Karloff like riding in on the stage in a
car and then they were like singing a
song together about how how monstrous
they were it was adorable it was
adorable okay I mean the thing about
Vincent Price that was cool too is that
you know he um he always had a sense of
humor about himself like he was very
willing to like parody uh you know just
like make light of all the characters
that he played and stuff like that
because he would always do these little
kind of jokes where he would turn up
like you know he was like he was on that
Canadian TV show like the hilarious
House of frightenstein which a lot of
people remember fondly I don't see we
didn't have it here but uh Canadians
[__] love it I think it was like some
local TV station in Ontario or something
I hadn't seen you in a while yeah Tammy
said Karloff was five eleven five eleven
okay yeah so not that much shorter but
yeah he wasn't six feet so much shorter
yeah yeah
that's actually my favorite Karloff and
Lugosi movies the black cat back in the
30s with the damn satanic ex military
commander sacrificing his unit to
consecrate the ground to build his
[__] futuristic satanic mansion and
dead women in refrigeration I guess they
were on ice or something and all this
damn necrophilia and if you're stealing
people's daughters that was a wild flick
man pre-haze cover Haze code yeah they
made some crazy [__] back there
and uh he looked tall
off dated that was the clothes and the
Angles and that that art deco black and
white way they kind of shot it it looked
really [__] cool spooky spooky
futuristic for the time yeah
that's a cool asset I can watch that
movie over and over again that's a cool
asset yeah that's one of my favorite
horror films of the 30s yeah I was just
it's funny because I was just watching a
video uh right before the show started
where um a guy was choosing his 10 top
10 favorite horror films from the 30s
and though like most of the ones he
picked were like totally legit picks but
yeah black cat was totally on there yeah
like you know imagine if that was
Vincent Price instead of Karloff
price could probably did a good job yeah
yeah I mean there was always something
like I said there was always something
about Vincent Price and it's funny
because you know like I said I'm
interested to like read the comments
like underneath all the documentaries
about him and stuff that are on YouTube
and a lot of people are like oh man he
scared me so much as a kid which is
hilarious because everyone said he was
like the nicest dude ever and it's funny
because a lot of people say the same
things about like Peter uh Peter Cushing
or like Christopher Lee or something
like that it's like they always played
like these monsters or like horrific and
not so much Peter Cushing but um you
know because he played he played with
Helsing and stuff too but I mean
Christopher Lee and everything like that
and everybody that meets them and said
he was just the the most generous
wonderful genuine down-to-earth person
and he just like you would never think
that he plays all these villainous roles
and I wonder if that's because you get
like all your bad [__] out playing
villains and then there's just nice
stuff left so like in your regular life
you're just a nice person because I hear
that about a lot of people that play
really horrible villains and stuff like
that they it's like you meet them in
real life and they're absolutely nothing
like that they're like the sweetest
people ever well it's like Michael
Rucker Michael Rooker plays now yeah
yeah he's friendly Mississippi guy yeah
uh even though he plays these like her
if he played like Henry like Henry
portrait of the series like Marvel Dixon
he's nothing like that
but and I think I think I think what it
is I don't think it has anything to do
with the roles I think what it is is
that uh certain people get elevated in
the career because they're easy to work
with behind the scenes like
okay here's a good example it's not
horror Clint Eastwood
Clint Eastwood had a [__] reputation
for being this badass Gunslinger and
hard you know Dirty Harry and [__]
you know High planes Drifter which is a
[__] badass Supernatural paranormal
flick that's like the Crow from [__]
the whole West but if you don't realize
it but yeah it's like an old west
version yeah
he's a REV he's come back from the dead
yeah that's all right to bring the town
to hell that's [__] great [__] but
anyway you would think that
with his [__] movie selection that
clintus would be a badass no
Clint Eastwood was a sweetheart that's
why that's why they hired him he was not
egotistical or arrogant at all and was
real quiet and was real polite and just
did exactly what he was told on set and
it was just like he was like an extra he
didn't walk around like he was a star
he was almost like they said he was like
working with an extra
see that's the thing because look nobody
I don't care how big a [__] star you
are nobody wants to deal with your
[__] ass yeah walking around thinking
your [__] don't stink and you're the
king of the [__] world nobody wants
to deal with that yeah so that's how
that's the reason why one of the main
reasons why Clint Eastwood became a star
and the reason why you know him he
looked great on camera with like hang
them high that's and uh and some of the
uh [__] Sergio Leone moves he just
looked [__] great
that was like the main thing but the
reason why he went over the top and had
such huge careers because everybody
could work with him everybody liked
working with him because he's
just too just laid back and it was like
dealing with an extra yeah he didn't
have to deal with any kind of Superstar
ego
yeah because like I said nobody could
wear on you nobody wants it yeah Zach
said and then there's Tom Cruise yeah
yeah then there's Tom Cruise
I was thinking the exact same thing yeah
well he Tom Cruise like uh he just
pushes it through he he breaks the
[__] boundary and and all of a sudden
once you start breaking a sound barrier
once you go through it it's all easy now
he's such an [__] that he just gets
anything he wants it's just like yeah
he's like he broke the sound it's kind
of like an [__] or a boros yeah yeah
once you break through it it now just
becomes like you know
or something
it's strapped
that's hysterical
but yeah I know like I said I never
heard a single person he's almost kind
of like Mr Rogers in that way I never
heard a single person say a say boo or a
bad word about Vincent Price everybody
just said he was a delightful delightful
man at all times I've never heard
anybody say a bad thing I'm sure
somebody has somewhere because that's
like really hard to find somebody on
Earth that somebody hasn't said
something bad about but I couldn't find
anybody saying anything bad about him
they just all said he was a wonderful
wonderful person and he sounds like a
wonderful person like I said he sounds
like pretty [__] rat
so uh yeah Tammy said yeah Clint was a
pretty boy in his day yeah he was
Slender though he kind of had a hard
look and he had real good eyes he had a
real good profile he could play a good
cowboy and uh
he wasn't very it was funny because in
the movies you know like and I love
Clint Eastwood movies you know if a pale
rider and
uh
High Plains Drifter Outlaw Josie Wales
[__] just classics
but he unrealistically beats the [__]
out of dudes you know he'll be you know
three dudes they're much bigger than if
you see him and a dude weighs like a
[__] 145 pounds he's skinny super
super skinny
but it kind of in high place Drifter
that was kind of an effective look
because he just looked like some kind of
Tumbleweed [__] range bum that just
kind of appears out of nowhere you know
he he looks ghostly because he is he's
supposed to be a ghost yeah so so I'll
allow it because he's actually
technically not supposed to be a human
yeah he's yeah he's a Revenant yeah now
he's good as long as he's slinging guns
but when you got him out there [__]
punching people and knocking them out
and all this kind of stuff
it doesn't play well today when you see
it because there's definite size
difference between him and other people
I mean his arms are like the size of a
broomstick you know he just he no no
muscle on him
he's built like a model
pretty much yeah yeah mego says if I
recall right I was about to bring this
up mango uh Clint's first movie was
revenge of the creature yes it was yeah
he actually had yeah I've seen it a
million because it was on MST well he
was like a scientist assistant yeah he
was in like one scene where like he had
something in his part or like a
chimpanzee like take something out of
his pocket or some [__] like that uh the
star of that movie I if I remember
correctly was wouldn't John Agar in that
[__] I wonder if John Agar was difficult
to work with because he always comes
across as such a condescending douche
like in every single movie or every role
that I've ever seen a man because he's
in a lot of movies that were on MST so
I've seen a lot of uh a lot of his stuff
he was in that one um what was that one
where they fell down to the in the
center of the earth and the mole people
the mall people yeah so he was in that
and it's just like he just [__]
mansplained the whole movie through and
I'm just like oh my God but somebody
just please punch him in the taint I
couldn't take it and so but so I
wondered if he was like that in real
life but yeah so John Agar was in
Revenge of the creature and uh Clint
Eastwood was like in a scene with him I
went out of my way to buy a Clint
Eastwood movie that that I saw uh on uh
it was I think I think I didn't get that
one off of Amazon I got that one off
[__] what's the other one eBay
I hadn't seen it since I was a kid oh
man I want to see this one I wonder if
it's as good as I remember the Firefox
never Firefox I saw that on cable back
in the 80s I I put it in and I couldn't
get halfway through it you're like wow
this sucks never just being a great
movie it's just boring you know what I
mean but see that's what I mean I kind
of feel like sometimes
you know particularly people that maybe
didn't live through the 80s and they're
kind of like romanticizing the 80s like
oh all the movies are bad so like there
are awesome movies from the 80s I'm not
saying that but there were a lot of
shitty movies in the 80s too and then
sometimes you saw movies back in the 80s
when you were a kid you were like that
was so [__] rad and then you see it
now and you're like it's like it's super
cringe yeah it was bad yeah it was real
low budget it didn't look that good on
screen look it was shot with a cheap
video camera it might have been because
I was watching it on HD television and
it just it upscaled too much you know
what I mean
the motion looked weird but it just in
the acting and everything it was just
off and not much happens in it
he just steals the Jet and then he
steals the jet but they're trying I
don't remember a single thing it seemed
exciting when you were a kid back in
that he's gonna go to Russia to steal
legit Russia it's on the other side of
the damn Planet yeah they got those
nuclear missiles and [__] that was back
here like yeah that was during the Cold
War so the Russia yeah Russia seemed a
lot more mysterious back then so
especially when you were a kid so always
going to Russia and he's stealing the
Jet and then you see the jet I remember
the jet being [__] badass you see it
now just look at the jet there's a delta
wing jet kind of like a [__] Valkyrie
and we never really look like kind of in
an SR 71 had a baby look you know it
looked kind of like that but when you
were a kid you were just like look at
that [__] jet you know
but you see it now you're like wait
whatever
it's a plane it's it's a plane yeah Mega
says I saw Firefox at the cinema back in
the day yeah so I said it would be good
for a remake yeah it probably did I kind
of wish like I said I kind of wish Tom
Cruise do it don't don't say that too
loud somebody might hear that but um
that's that's all we need
but that well that's the thing I kind of
feel like more people I wish that they
would take like movies that weren't all
that great
and take another swing at him you know
what I mean rather than like taking a
movie that was fine the first time
around and then like I said I can't it's
you know I'm not in charge of who gets
to remake movies or whatever but I do
kind of feel like you know yeah the good
[__] gets remade and I'm just like why
did they even bother why don't you take
a movie that was kind of sucky but was
like a good idea and remake that and
like try and get it right this time yeah
because there's plenty of those you'd
never run out yeah you know what I'm
saying
uh mango said the thing is he had to
control the jet with his mind but you
think in Russian just the way that's
right I forgot about that aspect it was
just the weapon system wow that's stupid
as hell yeah just the weapon systems
yeah I forgotten about that targeted
yeah it didn't make any sense yeah I
guarantee you Pilots have no problem
using the targeting system just to shoot
their thumb okay
yeah it's like it seems like it's much
harder to like try to control [__] with
your mind because then you have to like
keep your mind from wandering yeah yeah
I gotta take the car and get the oil
changed oh [__] you know what I mean
it's gonna be like that then after that
[__] I think it was what was it was
like a helicopter version it was Airwolf
not Airwolf it was Airwolf I think was
Blue Thunder that's what it was Blue
Thunder didn't have [__] what's the
name Shriver was in it
um the dude that was in Jaws was his
name Shriver
no uh Scheider Roy Scheider was in it I
think it was called Blue Thunder
I remember that one too yeah there's
some cops with a special [__]
helicopter it kind of reminded me of
Firefox at the time
because I think Firefox had come out a
couple years before
and then that thing comes out and that
that movie was [__] sucked too but we
loved it
now Thunder also Blue Thunder also an
awesome song by the band Galaxy 500. I
think it was called Blue Thunder I may
be wrong subjective perspective
Collective says uh I have a love-hate
relationship with Tom Cruise yeah we do
too well Tom is more on the love side
and I'm wrong I hate that I do like some
of his movies I'm not saying that but
every time I see him I just kind of want
to punch him
you know what I mean still
there's propaganda all this damn black
propaganda it's not propaganda again I
guess Tom all right no it's not it's
just my own eyeballs like looking at him
going man that guy seems like a real
douche
this [__] all began when he jumped up on
Oprah's couch that's what it did and I
didn't like him before that I didn't
know I didn't like him going back to the
80s ever since I saw risky business I
was like wow that guy is really a tool I
was watching that [__] when it happened
him jumping up on the couch
and yeah it was dumb as [__] you know I
would I would have done it but you're
dealing with Tom Cruise and he was doing
that in front of an audience filled with
adoring females
and he's playing to the crowd it's right
in front of him and those girls were
eating that [__] up in the studio
it just didn't play well outside the
studio I don't think people that hated
him hated him because of that I mean
like I said I hated him way before that
I didn't even see that when it happened
I just saw it later and then he goes on
about he didn't believe in um the
Psychiatry and them medicating people
and stuff which there there is some
there there is some to what he's talking
about uh Psychiatry and just a medical
practice in general has a real bad
history of making a lot of mistakes the
thing is though is that he's saying
Scientology should replace that [__]
right and I can't go with that you know
let's let's not go with that we've done
several shows about how shitty show Ron
Hubbard has no idea how the human body
and I have some personal experience I
wasn't in Scientology but I have some
personal experience with no working at a
company that was run by scientologists
if you're new here so right you know
yeah I've told that story a bunch of
times and uh no thanks I don't run
anything to do with that I got no
problem with attacking pseudoscience
problem is
Scientology is a pseudoscience so you
don't want to among other things
and it's a [__] racket yeah so lots
of things it's there's nothing good
about it please don't charge that
Scientology uh Victor says Tom Cruise is
one of my favorite Hollywood power
bottoms right well there's no evidence
of that there's no proof of him being
allegedly allegedly allegedly where the
whole thing came from let's be honest
he was in that movie where what was it
wasn't Ferris Bueller's Day Off was it
no he was what was what was that movie
what Risky Business risky business
that's where that's where the gay [__]
started
he slides across the floor this [__]
socks in his underwear [__] lip sync
thing at Old Time Rock and Roll Old Time
Rock and Roll dancing
the director wanted him to do that he
did it
[__] all these [__] gay men of
American [__] just he became the gay
heartthrob and because all these gay men
liked him he was what he's a teenager
when he did that I think right well he
was real young that was one of his that
was maybe his first big role I feel like
yeah
so you know
the gay dudes all fell in love with him
so then it it it it it tated him you
know I mean all the straight guys like
oh he's getting yeah
two hands when they pegged him [__]
no I'm just kidding that's all that's
allegedly
and please don't sue me no
there's no there's no evidence of
[__] Casting Couch [__] or anything
like that you know but um
that's what happened he became a gay
icon so people assume that he was gay
that's not what happened no I don't
believe yeah you don't have to be gay to
be a gay idea to be gay again there's a
lot of straight people that are gay
icons yeah vice versa I guess the uh
um
but uh if you you hear any Scientology
insiders they would tell you [__]
there's no way Tom Cruise's case he's
not gay he's straight
I'm I'm yeah I have new dog in that
fight yeah he's not he he's I'm not
interested in having sex with Tom Cruise
at any point these are supposedly people
that have bought it it doesn't matter to
me the people that have seen his
auditing material
okay yeah so all of the blackmail
materials yeah they know I was black man
because he's been um they audited his
ass on the [__] e-meter uh uh [__]
so he can [__] get rid of all his
body theatings and [__] and being gay
wasn't in there
yeah
that's the way I remember the story
like I said it doesn't matter to me
Marty Rathbone Marty Rathbone from the
church said no you're not gay no
no mango is talking about uh Blue
Thunder with Roy Scheider uh far better
than Firefox yeah have it on Blu-ray and
it's aged very well it has or I hadn't
seen it in a long time I remember I
remember it being pretty good but like I
said I think I was a teenager I remember
liking it but I just assumed it probably
wasn't any good because Firefox wasn't
any good I remember I thought of it kind
of like as a cop rip off of Firefox but
probably wasn't look yeah just I don't
remember that much about it I remember
they called that [__] dude jaffo just
another [__] [__] Observer
and then uh they were tracking down
somebody they found
some one of the cop friends was [__]
parked outside his girlfriend's house
they could tell he hadn't been along
because of the [__] motorcycle engine
was still hot there was it was just cool
he was a motorcycle engine
but they just had this damn super
helicopters I don't remember what it was
I think it was just a French gazelle
dressed up I don't think it looked kind
of like a look kind of like an age 64
Apache at the time but
it's been a long time since I've seen
that helicopter
it's probably a gazelle
mango Badger said yep it's tough being a
gay icon they love the badger breaks my
heart to tell them I'm a lesbian no okay
yeah
[__] happens man I love it
uh subjective perspective Collective
which I'm just gonna start calling you
SPC from now on
I remember a [__] ton of satanic
psychedelic price films from the VHS 80s
I mean I guess like he was still doing
I feel like his
he stopped doing movies he didn't stop
doing movies but he went way back on the
movies like after the 70s I feel like
like yeah he was still in some stuff in
the 80s and he was obviously an Edward
Scissorhands that was like his last role
but that was like only a few years
before he died because he was like
really really old he was actually
supposed to have like a larger role in
that but he couldn't because his health
was so bad that's one thing that um I
was watching this documentary about him
and he was
um lifelong friends with a very famous
actress Jane Russell like they met on a
movie set and they were like buddies for
their entire lives and she went to visit
him when he was sick and like dying and
stuff like that she's like that's the
only time she ever saw him like really
crabby because he was just like she said
he was so frustrated because he loved
life so much that he was mad that his
body had betrayed him you know what I
mean and he couldn't like get up and do
stuff anymore like he used to so he's
like he was just like yelling and
yelling about like don't ever get old
like I wouldn't advise it it's like
don't let anybody tell you it doesn't
suck it's like really really bad like
you know what I mean it's like that's
what I mean he had um I mean he smoked
for a long time so he had a COPD and I
think he ended up dying of uh lung
cancer if I'm not mistaken
but I mean he lived until he was in his
80s he was like I think he was 82 when
he died he died in 1993 and he was born
in 1911 so yeah 82. so I mean he lived a
long time but he was in very poor health
from
starting in like the 80s you know what I
mean which is why he didn't do a lot of
movies like in the 80s you know what I
mean
um okay so we can we talk about
Enterprise now let's talk about instead
of [__] Tom Cruise again yeah yeah
so we always talk about that
[__] it's like we we talk about
him almost as much as we talk about
[__] Steven Seagal and I don't even
want to get started on that because then
we'll just start picking on his fat ass
and we'll just like no we won't get
anything done Tom if you're out there
man I respect you bro that's good that's
good if Tom's watches it's Tom love yeah
yeah we're both in the short man Mafia I
got your back and I saw that damn Top
Gun flake that you do is good yeah
that's all right it was good for a Star
Wars remake oh
I mean that's pretty much what it was
right yeah it was it was a remake of the
night like it was it was a better read
it was an okay movie but I don't really
see why everyone was [__] themselves
over it was better than the last Jedi
but it was I mean it was just kind of
like kind of there yeah you know it was
a standard movie yeah it was like a
standard old-fashioned movie yeah it was
good
I could have done without the bar scenes
but it was all right
Mega said we need a cruise and Segal
movie right they need to like that would
be super funny
oh you know what they should do this
would never allow they should do like a
weird sci-fi thing where cruising cigar
swap bodies I'd watch that
they would never allow it
Scientology would never allow Tom Cruise
to be in the same movie that dude
I know it's a shame because that would
actually might be something that I would
consider watching
they're trying to get Steven Seagal to
be on [__] Expendables four I want to
see that
he like to sit down to the room yeah
Steven Seagal is the only dude that has
a stunt dog I knew I shouldn't have said
Steven Seagal okay what we're gonna be
talking about like [__] TV yeah
yeah Zach said I was just scrolling
through the old school cool subreddit
and found a pic of Vincent working on
his paintings yeah that's another thing
that maybe I don't know if people
that didn't grow up uh in the Heyday of
Vincent Price uh he was not only just an
actor he was also a very Avid art
collector uh his whole entire life and
he actually
um get into this in a little bit but he
um actually opened or um gave like a
bunch of his uh collection and a whole
bunch of money to an art museum in East
L.A which is still there like in East
L.A um Community College because he was
real big on and I want to talk about his
whole serious thing too because he got
gotten serious like selling art and
everything because he was so into art
that was what he wanted to do to start
with that was what he went to college
for but um that he thought that it
should be accessible to everyone and
that was like really really important to
him so that was another thing that he
was really into was like art collecting
so here's one thing that I didn't really
know now Vincent Price actually came
from money
um he came from like a a pretty wealthy
family I don't think they were like
Robber Baron wealthy but they were
pretty rich I actually was watching a
video earlier
um where it's this couple and they kind
of like go around tours and stuff and
they were in St Louis and they were
visiting like some sites having to do
with like Vincent Price's past so they
actually showed
um the house where he'd grown up like
where his parents lived until they died
in St Louis which was a beautiful
[__] house so it's like still there
it's like all kept up and everything
um I don't I wouldn't go so far as to
call it a mansion but it was for sure
enormous and it was brick and it was
just this gorgeous gorgeous house like
on the street I think it's Washington
Street Washington Avenue I can't
remember but it's like this big wide
beautiful Boulevard with like all these
really nice houses on it so that's where
his parents lived and uh oh and they
also went to downtown St Louis where
actually downtown St Louis because a
bunch of famous people have come from St
Louis like Chuck Berry and stuff like
that so they have um in downtown St
Louis they have like their own little
Hollywood Walk of Fame they have like
little stars on the you know in embedded
in the sidewalk and Vincent Price has
one and it's like right in front of the
art gallery there which I thought was
kind of nice they also have a statue of
Chuck Berry like right there in the
downtown which I also thought was pretty
cool
but yeah so his family came from money
how has family got the money is kind of
it's it's not funny but I mean it's
quirky it's unusual
so his grandfather whose name was also
Vincent Price
um and his dad's name was also Vincent
Price so I guess he's kind of like well
it's weird because they call him a
junior I guess because his grandfather
had a different middle name because
normally he'd be the third but yeah
because his grandfather was Vincent
Clarence price and then he was Vincent
Leonard price and then his dad was also
in Pennsylvania Enterprise so he was a
junior
but his grandfather actually invented
this the first this is so Random
the first uh like cream of tartar based
baking powder that was like the first
one on the market and it was called Dr
Price's baking powder and it was
apparently like a huge huge success and
he made like all the money so that's
where the price family got all their
money from was from this first cream of
tartar based baking powder like they
have even had little old-timey like cans
and [__] like that which I thought was
hilarious so that's where the family
money came from however his dad
his name was also Vincent Price
um owned a candy company like National
Candy Company and the video that I
watched earlier where they were in St
Louis the building is actually still
there they said it's a U-Haul now but
it's like this really really big like
cool building they said actually if you
was called the national candy company
and they still have like one of the
original signs like over the door that
looks like this little collage thing
like made of candy which is really cool
but yeah so his dad owned a candy
factory so everyone's like it's like
Willy Wonka kind of [__] but yeah so he
came from like
definitely like upper
middle class upper class circles for
sure
so
um he was also a descendant of the first
White child born in the new world
Peregrine White who was born on the
Mayflower uh original colonizer the
original colonizer yeah like his through
his I believe his mom's side of the
family he was related to to that baby
so he basically so he went to Yale
like when he got older and he got a
degree I believe a bachelor's degree in
English but he also had a minor in art
history and then he actually went on a
top for a year so he was a teacher and
um he said that he taught for a year and
then he realized he said he came to the
startling realization that he didn't
know anything I'm like yeah I know that
feeling but um yeah so he's like I don't
really want to teach anymore really he
wanted to
um
he wanted to do art he wanted to be an
art historian generally so he went to
London
and he was going to get his Masters in
Fine Arts
but while he was in London he actually
got sucked into theater and he decided
that he was really really into that and
that he would rather do that
so he actually started performing
professionally in the mid-1930s I think
his first stage performance was 1934 and
he also joined um you know Orson Welles
had the Mercury Theater
um he also was a member of that so he
got like in so like I said you were
saying before when I said that he came
from a real wealthy family who were very
um
you know like I said they weren't Robber
Baron rich but they were like Rich
enough that they were kind of like big
wigs in the community and all that other
kind of stuff it really help you in
Hollywood and that really does help you
well I mean you have the money to you
have the money to say no well and you
have the money to like have choices like
I said he you know I could never have
afforded to go to London to study or
anything like that because you know I
didn't have any money when I was younger
and my parents didn't have any money but
you know the fact that he could do that
he went to Yale and he did all this
other kind of stuff so yeah that always
does kind of help getting uh yeah when
you show up to Hollywood you know
looking for a job and you can act
you know they hire you some [__] they
offer you some [__] up roles I ain't
taking that which that already improves
your career yeah you say no
and so who are you I'm visit prize man
said [__] price I got money I don't
need to get my idea
that's that's real fast four best for
poor people I'm just doing this for more
people yeah I'm just doing it for fun
okay you're hired yeah
what role do you want yeah that's that's
exactly what could happen because you
negotiate from strength yeah you're not
showing up hey man I'll take anything
you give me you know we'll see I got
rent to pay I think that's kind of the
shittiest thing about being poor yeah is
you just kind of get you kind of get
like forced into situations that if you
had money you wouldn't have to get into
that right you know what I mean yeah
first first offer you get is some piece
of [__] movie that ruins your career but
you had to take it but you had to take
it because you had to like you got to
eat yeah you know what I mean
the thing about Vincent Price though and
I'm not really sure how much his
background like
um
maybe
uh played into this or you know
obviously it was probably just his
talent as well I'm sure it was a
combination of those two things but he
seemed like he was almost I don't even I
don't know if I'd call him like an
overnight sensation but for sure he
didn't really seem to go through because
you know how like a lot of actors
sometimes they'll be like man I worked
for like 10 [__] years in these
shitty at like I did commercials and all
this other kind of [__] and like nobody
noticed me and then finally they got
this big breakout role and then they got
famous and everything like that Vincent
Price didn't really seem to go through
that
um he basically like I said he went to
London to study Fine Arts then he
decided he was more into the theater so
he was going to do that he got right in
with the Orson Welles thing and he
basically got I think his first um uh
stage show that he did that he got like
real big notices for was uh Chicago like
he did some of that and then he was in
um this uh play called Victoria Regina
which is about you know Queen Victoria
and everything and he played uh Prince
Albert in that
probably yeah
yeah
um but yeah so he was in that and he
like immediately started getting really
good notices and when that play was
really successful and it came to the
United States he came with it like Helen
Hayes was in it as well she played
Victoria who was like she was like a
huge star at the time so I'm sure that
kind of helped he joked that he's like
yeah when the play came to the United
States I came over with the sets because
he had been like on stage in London but
he came over so when he came over and
they did the play over here like
immediately he was like a smashing
success everybody's like oh my God this
guy's amazing so I mean Hollywood pretty
much immediately like started calling
like I said he didn't really have any
period where he was struggling or
anything like that it just seemed like
he was immediately
famous you know what I mean like not
famous famous but
you know just getting kind of like
famous on the stage you know
so yeah so after this uh after he toured
with this
um play Victoria Regina for I think he
toured with it for a year and it was so
successful that you know you know they
called him up to start being in movies
now as I said even though he's known for
horror roles nowadays he actually
started out more in a lot more diverse
roles although he did tend to they
usually had him play historical figures
which I thought was kind of interesting
but he was like in a lot of Noir and
stuff like that like his first film role
was actually in 1938 and it was a movie
called service Deluxe which was actually
a comedy
um so he was in that as well but
um you know he played like uh Brigham
Young you know the guy that started yeah
yeah he played that he played um he was
in song of Bernadette so he he's in like
a lot of kind of period pieces I guess
because he came across as very even
though he was a Midwestern guy he came
across as very like I said Urbane and
very elegant and almost like European
even though he wasn't European well he
spoke in transatlantic if you noticed he
does have he does have his own personal
accent though there's no way to describe
it it's modified transatlantic yeah and
uh he sounds good yeah I can see why
some Americans thought he was European I
can too yeah he definitely comes across
like that yeah I think he's kind of
emulating British actors actually
some of them probably so yeah I mean he
seems to because we talk about this a
lot too like how British actors tend to
and this is just a generalization but
they do tend to take the the art of
acting like much more seriously maybe
well they got all that Shakespearean
theater right right back [__] a long
time they take the [__] seriously
Hollywood didn't
Hollywood started off kind of like in a
situation kind of like the circus
you know you could just get recruited
off the street that they liked you if
you're a good little girl and you blew
the right people you could be a star
they didn't take it that seriously
I feel like I mean people nowadays piss
and moan about like Hollywood this and
that but it's like it's always just like
that it's always been like that in the
sense that you know yeah there have been
actual like creative artistic people
working and making like masterpieces but
most of the time it's just like them
knocking off like some cheap Jack like
[__] movies just to make a buck like
off the Saturday matinee you know what I
mean yeah and even
even the Silver Screen and the Golden
Era of Hollywood
no it was bad back then too
Hollywood ran the town they ran the cops
a Hollywood a big a person big in
Hollywood could literally kill someone
and get away with it the cops would
cover it up you know it did happen it
happened a lot and then um
funny thing is is that
in California back in the Gold Rush era
and even you know the early California
Republic
you had a lot of brothels all right and
brothels and saloons
you had girls working in there that came
from out east
well those girls were in there and they
were the only girls in town a lot of
time they didn't really want to be
prostitutes they got hooked up in these
damn contracts it was basically slavery
you know indentured servitude
a woman doesn't want to really be a
hooker for a living you know what I mean
in a brothel
so they would learn to play instruments
and sing and they would put on little
stage shows
and they would put their name outside in
front in a star that's where that's
where the the idea of a person of a girl
being a star came from that
so
a hooker and a star was synonymous back
in the 1800s and that carried on into
Hollywood when a girl was a star she was
a hooker too
a lot of those famous actresses they
maybe they weren't prostitutes when they
started out but when they got in there
you had to it wasn't just Casting Couch
[__] they were sleeping with producers
and that's where the money came from to
get the movie in the first place it was
[__] it was the skin trade
early 1900s if you if you were an
actress a Hollywood actress that was
tandem out of being a hooker
I don't think modern people realize that
they uh at least in California culture
of the old time uh the actress was a
hooker star of the hooker they were just
kind of high class about it
so yeah so like I said
um mostly Noir kind of films in the 30s
uh in some comedies and some dramas
period dramas that kind of stuff he
plays like I said a lot of historical
figures now the first horror movie that
he did was in 1939 and it was Tower of
London that also had Boris Karloff in it
and then in 1940 he was actually in the
sequel to The Invisible Man
um The Invisible Man returns I think
they couldn't get um who was in The
Invisible Man collaborate it was Claude
Reigns wasn't it
um I think that he couldn't come back
for the um for the sequel for whatever
reason and so
um Vincent Price like took over the role
of the invisible band in 1940 in the
sequel so he's in that too so he
actually did start out like you know
doing a few horror movies as well and
Zach mentioned earlier like a couple of
other movies like Dragon Wick and leave
her to heaven with uh Gene Tierney
uh who was also in Laura and those were
also in the 1940s and then he started
getting more into like Noir and like
playing villains and I feel like he got
to a point where
he sort of at least according to his
daughter like I was watching an
interview with her but she said there it
came a point where he like was playing
these villains and he's like this is
like my this is my wheelhouse you know
what I mean he seemed to really enjoy
playing villains and he was really
really good at it yeah so I kind of feel
like that
after that point I kind of feel like he
I don't think he really started to get
Typecast Typecast until maybe House of
Wax like after that because that was
such a big huge hit that they weren't
expecting and he plays like such a
demented character in that I love House
of Wax By the way I don't think we've
ever done the 1953 original highway now
when you start getting into the demented
[__] fence and price horror movies I
really wouldn't call that acting I would
call it performing he's a performer he's
great but it's none of it's believable
it's not supposed to be that's not the
tone of it he's just having a good time
having a good time so the time and he
wants you to have a good time yeah yeah
that's what's cool about him and he's
kind of putting his own [__] trade
he's putting his own signature on every
roll he's kind of playing the same guy
in a way but you know it's okay that's
that he had a fan base and people came
to see him and then he knew what he was
doing mr88 said uh England produces
thespians in the United States produced
movie stars yeah it'd be a good way to
put the
the British when it came to acting in
English they had that [__] [__]
nailed going all the way back to [__]
Shakespearean days you know Shakespeare
a uh that's where English or in English
theater came from
America was kind of aping it with movies
but it was just more mass production it
wasn't as there was no television so you
had to do it through movies it was they
would make a lot of them you know it was
just a lot of it was just kind of slip
shot you had some good movies though
it's just that most of them weren't and
uh they were very forgettable and they
were kind of like built on a formula a
lot of them
but uh even today
if you come across a good series
seems like it's an American Series in
English
and even movies the best actors and
actresses in there are going to be
British
you won't notice that they'll even have
American accents and everything you know
like in The Walking Dead I couldn't
believe that old dude was [__] not
from Georgia that sounded like a George
index Andy Lincoln yeah I was like yeah
that's a real Southerner there no he's
British yeah so the dude talking his own
voice and I was like what the [__]
and then like you see an interview and
you're like why are you talking like
that yeah yeah and
um the dude that played uh here's not
here [__] what was it got uh uh the
black dude
Southern black guy man that dude [__]
nailed it like I said I'd seen him in
some other things yeah well I should
have you know Andrew Lincoln prior to
Walking Dead was in Love Actually but
because I'm not a rom-com girl uh I
actually had not seen that yeah so I
didn't realize that he was British
either until later
flip it around the other way when you
have an Americans doing British accents
you're gonna end up with like [__] it
doesn't it doesn't always end up so well
Keanu Reeves
we're sorry we don't want to play
because I love it oh yeah his his news
but his British accent is in uh Dracula
was just terrible so so bad um Winona
Ryder's wasn't that great either no I
mean no
no
no well they just learned in a couple
days you know I've heard British people
do in cheap British movies I got an
insulin Hammer not I don't think it was
a hammer movies that other horror
uh company that they had for back in the
60s and they had a character who was
supposed to be an American it was all
[__] up no don't worry so not every
British person could do an American
accent but it's usually
useless well then the other way around
and I'm not really sure why that is yeah
I don't know because I was like every
British person I've ever met
um they were just like oh I can't talk I
can't do that like they can't do an
American accent I said I could probably
do a British accent but I'm not gonna do
it because I just embarrassed myself
Victor says 90s Keanu Reeves made me gay
lots of things made you gay Victor
[Laughter]
also seems like a really nice person so
I always say he's cool I always kind of
like hate to [__] on him because of his
accent and Dracula no he Geeks out on
motorcycles and guns that looks really
bad he can't Reeves can shoot I've seen
him at the range he's he is good what's
that [__] series that he does now
John Wick John Wick I've seen one two
and three I have one and two saw three
in the theater we haven't seen four yet
we're gonna have to rent that I saw that
it just came out on streaming but it's
probably like 20.
I imagine I think you can only buy it I
don't think you can rent it yet I'll buy
it on Blu-ray
and I need three too and those are
[__] fantastic movies
Keanu can can he can entertain but he
can shoot and that's the kind of movie
he needs to be in it's just kind of a
fantasy gangster shoot him up movie
just good really good entertaining
I want to revisit them all because they
were visually stunning
remember how good one and two were in
three they just looked great Mega said
John Wick 4 is amazing that's what they
say they say it's just yeah I've heard
that great yeah I want to see it I want
to see it too like I said I just noticed
it came up on Amazon Prime like to buy
but I'm sure it's like probably 20.
Mr 88 says chicken or the egg do we
associate Vincent Price's voice with
horror because he was in so many horror
movies or was he in so many horror
movies because of his voice
no no it's because he was in so many
horror movies I mean well the thing
about it I mean all of the movies that
he did and he did 100 hundreds it was
like at least I don't somebody said 200
I don't know if it was that many but it
was like for sure over 111 yeah it was
for sure over 100.
um I Heard somewhere that less than a
third of those were horror movies
so but those are the ones people ever
like everybody remembers the most
obviously because like I said horror
fans were nerds you know what I mean and
I'm not that's no shame I'm one too so
I'm just saying that
if you make a really good classic horror
movie people are gonna remember that
[__] forever you make a good classic
drama
maybe people remember it maybe not 50
years from now will people still be
watching it
Maybe maybe not horror movie definitely
they'll definitely be watching that [__]
they don't give a [__] if it's 50 years
old they don't give a [__] if it's 100
years old [__] I still watch silent
movies
I watch [__] that's more that's more
than a century old and I still enjoy
that so you know what I mean it's and I
and I don't know if other sub-genres
really have that and that's pretty good
like coming from a genre that's still
it's a lot better than it used to be but
it was still like um kind of
disrespected I feel like because it feel
like you know if you're in horror movies
people like kind of looked at scans like
you were slumming or something you know
if you were an actor which I always
thought was kind of shitty because I was
like why is that why do people [__] on
[__] horror and sci-fi they're just
as legit I don't think they really do
that anymore not anymore it's not it's
not like it used to be those are older
Generations that are gone now
and I think a lot of it had to do with
in the 50s
and even to a certain extent the 60s
sci-fi and horror were kids matinee
movies yeah adults didn't go see him
that was like seeing He-Man or some [__]
like that they didn't care about that
the [__] the phone's ringing yeah so I
think I think it had more to do with the
50s but let's see if we're all dead now
yeah they were old in the 50s I mean it
definitely I kind of feel like that was
fading away like in the 80s and 90s
television killed
television killed the prejudice against
[__]
yeah think about it
because movies could no longer be
daytime television for kids
you know what I mean had to get more
upscale
and then all those horror movies ended
up being played on television or people
actually saw some of them some of them
was good like them was really good
you know
uh it is yeah you know so so some of the
[__] stuck
yeah
and then he started making the new
generation of guys came out started
making better horror movies
you know
John Carpenter Can't Make the thing that
[__] blew you out of [__] water
man it's not one of my favorites of all
time an alien came out oh man so you had
good horror and it was mixing with
sci-fi
which those those are two forbidden
genres back in the 50s it was going to
be bad that was like for kids or it was
like shitty chips because I kind of feel
like when people thought of like horror
movies or sci-fi movies from the 50s
they thought of like big bug movies yeah
now some of those were good though most
of them were like really shitty have you
shown alien and alien 2 to a 1950s
audience it has scared the [__] out and
they would have liked it I think they
would have liked it
I always kind of Wonder like if I didn't
see that though if I invented a time
machine I would just I would like to do
that just out of carry out I know it
would cause like time Rifts and like you
know the butterfly effect and everything
but still it's just like yeah what if
you could take
alien yeah and take it back to the 1930s
it's 30s they would they would have
liked it probably yeah maybe later maybe
the 50s would be like a better time but
you took it back to the 30s and like
showed it people they would blow their
[__] minds that would blow their
[__] people the 20s and 30s were a
lot more hardcore than they were of the
50s
in a weird way when it came to movies
there was pre-haze so they'd they you go
back to the 30s and show [__] alien
one to them and they go oh yeah yeah
that's awesome they'd like that space
outer space does it look like that in
outer space you know they would because
you know they weren't sure what outer
space looked like in the 1930s they
still weren't in the 50s because I feel
like they had a lot of their sci-fi
clouds it's like it's yeah they got
clouds in space they're walking around
on the outside of the spaceship yeah you
open up the window the window on a
spaceship hey drop my window yeah yeah
not the spaceship because it went farted
in there yeah yeah and then you know
what I mean and then like everybody's
like there's aliens on the moon and [__]
like that yeah they didn't know [__]
in the 50s uh but yeah
so yeah so he's in a bunch of more
movies and stuff like that like during
the 1940s like the late 1940s now here's
something that's interesting they said
that his first starring role because
prior to that he'd been kind of like you
know the second guy or like you know
character actor type of guy
he said that it says that his first
starring role was in a movie called The
Baron of Arizona which was like a biopic
and that came out in 1950. interestingly
when I was on Amazon Prime last night
and I you know as I mentioned earlier
that I watched the movie shock and I
think that was from 1946. that says on
Amazon Prime that that was Vincent
Price's first starring role so
because I mean if it did come out I mean
he was like pretty much the star of that
so I'm not really sure like what they're
using as like starring role type of
material but I would have called that a
starring role and that was earlier so
I'm just saying
um also something else that he did from
the late 1940s till the early 1950s was
he was on uh the radio show the saint
playing Simon Templar so there was that
as well now his first kind of big
breakout horror role as I mentioned
earlier was in 1953 with House of Wax
which is a great [__] movie if you
haven't seen it House of Wax I think was
only now some sources say that it was
the first 3D movie it wasn't there was
actually one prior to it but I think
that that one came out like only like
the same year as House of Wax so it was
like a very new thing like this 3D uh
thing thank you John Robert Robertson
hey guys I just found out that Vincent
Price never played a vampire role ever
except in Monster club which wasn't
really a serious role yeah I feel like
he joked around about it a couple times
like he never played Dracula or anything
like that even probably even made it
good yeah but um but he did like kind of
fart around with the Vampire thing like
I think like when he was on
um like variety shows and stuff like
sometimes he would put on like the
vampire get up and I think didn't he
have fangs on um
Muppet Show or No Kermit had fangs
didn't Kermit bite him on the neck I
thought Kermit like opened his mouth and
Kermit had fangs and then Kermit bit
Vincent Price I don't know if I'm
remembering correctly I haven't seen it
in a while
but yeah he never did play uh a vampire
did he he usually put he seemed to play
like a lot of well later on he always
played like Mad Men kind of he was good
at that Sorcerers yeah that kind of [__]
that kind of [__] yeah
um but yeah somebody mentioned uh the
Mad Magician yeah he was in that too
that was 1954 so I'm talking of Mad Men
and he was also in the fly and return of
the fly he didn't I thought about it he
didn't play he didn't play the flat the
guy with the flyhead no he played wasn't
he his brother or his brother-in-law I
don't remember it's been a while since I
forgot that he was in it though yeah he
was in it yeah yeah it was like a major
role
um but I really like that movie actually
I was watching a documentary and they
showed the final scene you know
obviously everybody now knows the David
Cronenberg one from eight from the 80s
which is also an amazing film yeah but
the one from the 50s is like still
pretty [__] cool
that last scene where
defensive price like finds the fly body
with the human head on it yeah stuck in
the spiderweb yeah going help me and
then like the spider comes and like
bites his head oh that's still like [__]
I was like God that's horrible yeah like
for 1953 like just to [__] thinking
about it I don't know like you think
about it now because it's just like oh
is it it was a dumb movie from the 50s
but I'm just like think about the
[__] implications of that that's
awful yeah there's a human being flying
around like a fly yeah with his head and
he thought and he's like looking and you
can see like his tiny little face in
this big [__] spider comes and like
bites his head and then the whole movie
right there Jesus Christ be a whole
movie right there to be the fly the
actual little man fly I don't like
that's awful and with the dude never
make that now the dude the dude the dude
that was playing the fly that was
getting eaten by the spider
was it the same actor that played the
the scientist fly
was that him I think it was yeah yeah
because it would have to be like I said
it has it's better so he just he's
transferred over there
yeah that's a weird [__] huh can you
imagine being tiny and like having your
[__] head bit off by a spider and
like knowing that this but oh my God
that's awful that's like one of the
worst things there was no way to save
him you couldn't get them both together
and put them back in into the [__]
machine and get him [__] sorted out
because you lost that that one you lost
part of him yeah I'm talking about yeah
although it probably wouldn't work would
it
to put him back in the machine together
and tell them well that's what they were
trying to do weren't they okay that's
why they were trying to find because
obviously they had scientists who had a
big huge flyhead yeah and then you had a
fly body with like a tiny little human
head okay and so they were trying to
like Vincent Price like I said he was
either the guys I think he was his
brother he was either his brother or his
brother-in-law I can't remember so he
was like telling this little kid he's
like um because the little kid is like
hey I saw that fly because he's like
looking for he's like have you seen like
a fly with like a weird white head yeah
like somewhere in the garden because
they wanted to like put him back in the
like in the in the matter transference
machine
put him back again yeah that's right he
had a human arm today that was [__]
yeah but I was just like watching that
scene again I was like Jesus Christ
that's awful can you imagine like what
that would be I'm like that's pretty
[__] hardcore for like 1950s like I
said I know everybody talks about like
the David Cronenberg one which didn't
have that going on but
I was like I don't know that that's also
pretty awful and then like Vincent Price
has to like smush him with a rock like
before the spider like digests him and
I'm just like yeah
terrible they had put him out of his
misery right that's what I mean it's
just like oh my God that's like it's
[__] horrifying the more I thought
about it like the more horrified I got
so uh so yeah so that was like
throughout the 1950s and this I feel
like is when Vincent Price start because
House of Wax was like a massive even
though it was like it wasn't really it
didn't cost that much to make but it was
like a huge huge hit
and um
after that and then since he did the fly
and everything and the Mad Magician so
everyone just started to associate him
like it was his breakout role for sure
but then everybody just started he's
like oh he's the horror guy now so like
I said he did get Typecast in a way but
you know which I think maybe bummed him
out a little bit although he didn't
really seem to complain about it all
that much
um because he did seem to be having a
good time playing villains and stuff but
he did seem to become indelibly like
associated with the horror genre from
that point forward I think it was
probably House of Wax That kind of
sealed that
um so yeah then he started his
association with William Castle yeah
it's another dude we should do a show
about that dude's fascinating William
Castle he was kind of like um he would
make all those like low budget films
that had all those like gimmicks you
know what I mean so uh two of them I
think we've covered both of these on the
show The Tingler for sure
because I remember doing that one not
too long ago and The Tingler which is
actually like a much better movie than
it sounds because it sounds like it
sounds like a sex toy I'm not gonna lie
but it's actually like about if you
haven't seen it it's about like this
weird it's a centipede like bug thing
and it like gets in your spine and it
feeds on fear right and like and so
William Castle the gimmick for that
movie when it came out was that some
theaters not all of them obviously but
some kind of special theaters would have
little buzzers like um attached to the
back of some of the seats so in the
scenes in the movie where like The
Tingler was you know invading or like
getting somebody or it's like there was
a scene in the movie Where The Tingler
gets loose in a movie theater like in
the movie and so they would set off the
buzzers on some of the seats so
everybody would like scream and freaking
obvious when you saw I saw the seat
temperature in a bit Yeah I'd be curious
to know because it's like this was
before I was born yeah I remember
watching that movie and their
explanation of Where The Tingler came
from I remember just I don't remember
exactly was just remember that it was so
[__] hokey it's so implausible what
was it it was a it wasn't an alien it
was something from another dimension now
it wasn't from another dimension what
was it I don't find it get in you it was
invisible wasn't it no you can see it
okay now I can't remember it's like we
haven't we saw it not that long ago
because we
um it would get in you somehow and it
would grow it would go all down your
spine underneath the skin yeah right
like it yeah it feels like I said it fed
on fear
yeah where'd it come from they gave it I
can't remember they did it didn't make
any sense to me it wasn't it wasn't a
scientific explanation well none of
those movies yeah I was just like like I
said and I always and I pulled this out
like every single time we talk about
like dumb pseudoscience like in 50s
movies
um what was the movie about was it the
uh the amazing colossal man or the
sequel which is uh the Colossal [__] I
can't remember that the Colossal [__] no
that's not what it's called but um it
was I can't remember what the sequel was
called I'll remember in a minute they
were both on Mystery Science Theater
anyway but there was one like um there
was one line in there
where he says just like like it's the
most natural thing in the world like
everybody knows this oh well everyone
knows like the heart is one single cell
I'm like no no it's made of I'm like
pretty sure they knew that even in the
50s yeah they would pull [__] out of
their ass so like yeah the next star
over is [__] ten thousand I'm like
you think that like whoever wrote the
screenplay would have been like maybe I
should call a doctor about that is that
right yeah
no they don't know anything
let me just put that [__] out of their
ass they're like did this then this must
come from another solar system [__]
that's over 5 million miles away
that's part of you guys yeah Five
Million Miles Away ah [__] that's right
here yeah I mean relatively speaking
Yeah but yeah the the thing about what a
light year was the thing about the heart
being one cell always kind of got me
because I was like that seemed like
something that was really really easy
it's a Tingler I thought they said that
it was a part it was an organelle or an
organ in your body
that under certain circumstances would
grow into that oh wait maybe it was
that's what I thought it was and it
didn't make any goddamn sense no it
didn't but like I said it wasn't it
wasn't the dumbest thing that I heard in
the 50s maybe that's for sure
but yeah so yeah so he was in The
Tingler The Tingler I think I don't know
if this is
um the case
but I remember being really Blown Away
by them being like a large plot point
being around LSD in The Tingler and I
was like is that the first movie where
they did that were they like based kind
of because I don't remember one before
that I mean well I know LSD like wasn't
really invented before that but I think
that was the first movie that made LSD
like kind of a big
plot Point like and they even The
Tingler where they even say like they
even call it LSD and like it's kind of a
thing it was probably Cutting Edge
experimental that's what I'm saying so I
so I thought that was kind of
interesting too so I don't know if it
was the first movie to mention it or use
it as part of the plot but it was for
sure one of the first a lot of these
so-called High [__] Tech street drugs
that they have today turned out a lot of
[__] they had that [__] in the 1800s
they had ecstasy in the in the late
1800s I didn't know that well I mean you
know yeah chemistry is chemistry yeah
what do they call it there's nothing new
Under the Sun no like there's always
like a variation and some [__] yeah
going way back Doc Holliday just go down
his dentist just carry around a whole
jar of cocaine
here's my jar
and that's why yeah
Darian Rose says absolutely loves the
old Vincent Price movies even in high
school I do too I was like I'll watch
pretty much anything he's in anything
so yeah
so he's in The Tingler with William
Castle the other one probably more
famously uh that he did with William
Castle was House on Haunted Hill which
man I still love House on Haunted Hill
that might be my second or third
favorite I've seen that like a million
times
um and that one the the uh the gimmick
for that one was called emergio I
remember that and during some because
you know like at the climax if you I
feel like everybody's probably seen
house on Hunter Hill but um during the
climax where like the skull the skeleton
like comes out of the Acid Bath or
whatever yeah um yeah like they would
have the theaters they had like
basically they just had like a plastic
skeleton or something like that like off
in the wings and it was on a string so
it would come out like at that critical
moment in the in the movie and it would
just like come up like over the audience
so everybody'd be like holy [__] a real
skeleton you know what I mean so that
was I love that they called it emergio
like it was something other than like a
skeleton on a string thank you very much
Jeff you are thank you Jeffy art
[Laughter]
yeah
Camp guy said our nearest star is four
four years away if you're traveling at
light speed yeah over 24 trillion miles
yeah yeah well [__] man in the 50s they
say now it's 5 million miles you don't
know what you're talking about
far real far
yeah yeah I don't really think they had
a really good handle well that's the
thing and that was always kind of what
made me mad about that whole like heart
being one cell thing I'm like [__] they
knew that that was not the case in the
50s they knew that they the people
writing these scripts just pull [__] out
of their ass like no one will ever know
yeah maybe they just thought well just
like a bunch of snot-nosed little kids
are going to be watching this if he
gives a crap like why even bother
yeah I guess they didn't bother yeah
maybe not which is kind of that's kind
of sad
but yeah so um if you haven't seen House
on Haunted Hill it's it's great uh I
actually like the original because they
kind of remade it I feel like in the
didn't they remake it in the 90s or some
[__] I don't know
um they remade a lot of the movies from
back in the 90s and I didn't love them
but I really really like again probably
one of my favorite Vincent Price movies
he's just [__] I don't know like he's
just [__] great in this you know what
I mean in that movie I just really like
his uh character even though like Tom
was saying he can't I don't want to say
he like he kind of plays the same
character every time because he doesn't
but he always has that perfect
combination of like elegance and
villainy like you know what I mean like
he's kind of like charming and Suave and
everything like that but also like kind
of sinister and it's like he was oh he
was just really good at like striking
that balance you know what I mean and I
thought and I think that House on
Haunted Hill was one of my favorite
roles where he like did that
um but yeah so he even though he was
mostly in horror films at this point he
was still in some other [__] too um some
people pointed out he was in The Ten
Commandments um it wasn't a huge huge
role but yeah he was uh in that as well
and he was on he was like doing a lot of
um TV
and then
um right around the 1960s
he started hanging with Roger Corman now
like I said Roger Corman that's man we
should do a show about Roger Corman and
William castle that would be like a
really good show
um Roger Corman
uh gave a lot of people their start and
he would basically
make a movie in a week and then he's
like hey we can use these sets again
let's make a whole other movie you know
what I mean and he never lost money on a
single movie that's what I heard anyway
but he decided that he was going to
start making these adaptations of Edgar
Allan Poe stories because obviously post
stories are in the public domain and a
lot of people
um you know had read them and like they
were very popular stories so he's like
you know we can make some kind of low
budget
adaptations of these and so Vincent
Price big fan of Edgar Allan Poe which
who isn't really I kind of feel like
everyone is but
um so they started
doing all these adaptations honestly all
of which are great I kind of feel like
um
I don't know I feel like most people
probably
think pit in the pendulum is maybe the
best one
I think mask of the Red Death is the
best one but they're all good I mean
they're all good
um but he was in pitting the pendulum
Tales of Terror which was like an
anthology
um comedy of Terrors The Raven which was
a cop which was also a comedy masculine
Red Death like I said in Tomb of liegea
so they did all of those like in the
1960s and I kind of feel like those are
probably the most iconic roles that
Vincent Price is known for nowadays like
if you don't if you haven't seen any of
his other movies I feel like probably
you've seen most of the
most of the Corman Poe adaptations
because those were legit good movies and
I'm not going to say that all of Roger
corman's movies were good because they
weren't like a lot of them were kind of
were pretty shitty
um and a lot of them were
uh padded big time like you see you see
something like
um didn't you make like uh I think it
was Teenage caveman
I think like legit 20 of that movie is
just like people walking around yeah
as far as driving right so you can tell
that they were really trying to like get
to a movie like just go walk around down
out in the mountains for 20 minutes car
pulls in the parking spot and then later
on the car pulls out of the parking spot
when they leave just anything to pad the
movie yeah they did that [__] yeah
so a lot I feel like a lot of Roger
corman's movies are like that but man
mad respect to the dude
um he got he gave so many directors
their starts and he did make some
actually really good movies and the PO
ones are his best ones I feel like but I
mean he made a lot of shitty stuff too
but like I said he didn't lose money on
anything because he definitely knew what
he was doing didn't Roger Corman do uh
Galaxy of Terror he did that's [__]
it I love galaxies yeah that's a great
movie yeah [__] Galaxy Terror was
great and uh had Sig Hague Sid Hague was
in it that's right [__] a girl from
[__]
Happy Days
yeah Aaron Moran and Moran was in it
and uh and you get to see a woman get
raped by a giant maggot yeah so so
there's that it's more like a [__]
caterpillar well but uh yeah
and what was funny is that I mean it was
a case it was an alien rip-off yeah
and uh from that rip-off who made that
the special effects was Cameron
and James Cameron yeah James Cameron and
from that ripoff
that's how he got the job for aliens or
alien too yeah because of galaxy of
Terror see like I said Roger Corman
Roger yeah Tara looks good yeah it's
real good even though people kind of
[__] on him he's like oh he'd make
movies for like five bucks or something
like that and make like you know three
movies in on one set which he did yeah
uh he was you know he's Thrifty and the
[__] funny thing about Galaxy of
Terror is it's got like a [__] little
story that sandwiched in it an intro and
an outro and it's got the main villain
and it's Martin the Martian who's that
guy's name
that actor that played [__] of the
Martian from Martin my My Favorite
Martian oh right right
um [__] oh it's running I had it I had
it as it come out of it I had it yeah oh
it was right there yeah he's the main
bad guy he basically basically plays the
devil God what's his [__] name I
forgot that guy's name is I just had
like right you were talking and I was
like oh and then the Martian and it just
and Bill Bixby Bill Bixby doing that guy
flickered away terminal someone will
know it or someone will Google it yeah
or I'll remember it like in five minutes
probably
um but yeah so he did all the PO
pictures like in the early 1960s and
then 1964 he did last man on Earth which
we did a review of not too long ago
which if you don't know was the first
adaptation of the classic Richard
Matheson novel I Am Legend uh which was
also made into uh there thank you thank
you I was like I had it I had it it's
like thank you I knew somebody would
know yeah two people Ray Walston yeah
um yeah I could see his face and I was
like oh his name was I want to buy a
Galaxy of Terron Blu-ray it's expensive
though I want to own that movie I mean
that's a that's a good that's a
legitimately it's a legitimate good
sci-fi horror it's alien one ripoff
but alien two is a rip-on the alien two
is still it's still its own thing but
the way it looked I mean it looked good
well that was [__] James Cameron did
the special effects
yeah some of it looks amazing yeah and
then you [__] look you go back and
watch Galaxy of Terror and you know all
the matte shots and [__] and a lot of
the stuff that happens in the interior
stuff when they're in the [__] alien
pyramid
you can see where they got ideas for
[__] aliens for alien too yeah come
around there and [__] see the
equipment and some of the costumes it
looks it looks good for a Roger Corbin
flick looks real good
it's kind of a hokey story
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter back
then we were teenagers and we'd watch
that [__] on [__] Cinemax or [__]
HBO over and over and over again
sneaking [__] in my days we were
sneaking [__] everclearing and
drinking that drinking ever clear and
[__] Hawaiian Punch watching that
[__] dreaming about girls trying to get
laid yeah this is good times I mean the
thing about movies is that I don't care
how much it costs to make it I don't
care what the plot of it is I don't care
just entertain me that's all I don't
care what genre it is you know obviously
I'm more into horror and stuff like that
but it's just kind of like any movie can
be good you can make a movie on your
phone for ten dollars they could be a
[__] Masterpiece yeah all it's got to
do is enter just don't bore me that's
all just don't bore me Sly did you see
Galaxy of Terror bro we're about the
same age we were probably doing the same
[__] at the same time we're watching
Galaxy of Terror on [__] cable trying
to get laid drinking Ever Clear in the
South
Zach says what would you say is Vincent
Price's best performance
I don't well best performance are my
favorite performance like I said I
probably my favorite film of his is mask
of the Red Death however
um I think maybe
performance wise he might have done
better in House of Usher interestingly
his favorite acting performance and the
favorite acting performance of many of
his friends and family was actually not
in a movie but was actually a one-man
stage play that he did in the 70s where
he was like um he was playing Oscar
Wilde
and he said that was like his favorite
role and a lot of people said that was
his really like his best I wish I could
see it somewhere I don't think that
anyone recorded it because like I said
it was a 70s yes it's Galaxy of Terror
1981. yeah
yeah
so uh yeah so what did I talk about okay
so last man on Earth yeah we talked
about that
um like I said if you don't know that's
based on Richard Matheson's I Am Legend
which was also made into the Omega Man
with Charlton Heston and I am Legend
with Will Smith which man but I do like
the Omega Man though but the last man on
Earth is actually
the closest by far to the novel
um I'm still waiting for them to make
like I said a a really accurate
adaptation of the novel but the last man
on Earth is the closest
um it's fairly fairly close that's
actually my favorite Vincent Price movie
is Last Man on Earth that yeah that
one's great and I [__] love Omega Man
with with chested Charlton Heston no I
love that movie too and they're they're
similar they're they're based on a
similar story
they're based on the same story yeah
it's the same book yeah the book's great
too if you haven't read it I mean I love
all Richard Mathis I prefer Omega Man
out of the two but I like uh I like last
man on earth oh that's closer to the
book too in glass man yeah way closer
yeah way closer
um also oh this is another one too
because I'm thinking of like all the
movies that he was in uh also in the
late 60s 1968 he also did witchfinder
General yeah which was actually known as
the Conqueror worm over here but I just
call it Wishbone in general and I think
we reviewed that one did we review that
one together or did I just do that one I
can't remember but man he was like not
Vincent Price was not campy at all in
that movie he was scary as [__] because
he was like completely [__] sadistic
you know what I mean he didn't have any
of that I think that was probably like
his scariest role because there really
seemed no humor in it he was playing a
real guy like Matthew Hopkins like a
real witch finder and man what a [__]
bastard yeah like but it's still a great
movie though but that's that's a great
[__] performance yeah she's like yeah
burn the witches subjective he he
mentions the Will Smith version of Mega
yeah for you guys that don't know there
was a third movie based on that book
called I Am Legend which is the name of
it which is the name of the book with
Will Smith in it and when it came out I
didn't like it but I I think I just saw
it being played on a movie channel
and it I got thrown out of it or
something I didn't like it but we rented
it and watched it again and I liked it
the second time
it's a lot better than I remembered it
Will Smith's good in it
it's not as good as Omega man there's
just something about a Mega Man uh I
like that that's telling that story the
main problem with the Will Smith version
is that the mutants don't talk and
that's a big part of the [__] movie
is that the mutants should be able to
talk and they're just like CGI vampire
yeah there's kind of I'm like which has
been done before yeah the cross between
a vampire and a zombie yeah which I'm
like and and so that meant he was by
himself
in a [__] apocalyptic world
post-apocalyptic world but there's
nobody to talk to him it's kind of no
those things should have been able to
talk it should have been like an Omega
Man or in [__] last man on Earth
they could talk they had their own
civilization they saw him as the master
and they wanted him gone
and we see that soul I mean the whole
point of the book this is what always
like pisses me off the whole point of
the book I Am Legend was that he was the
monster he was the only human left in a
world of like quote unquote mutants
which are essentially vampires but not
exactly like vampires but similar
so he's the only one left so he's the
monster because he's going around like
killing them while they sleep because
he's still interpreting them as monsters
because he's still interpreting things
the way things used to be
anymore like and he doesn't understand
that he's like The Last Remnant like you
know his species is gone now like this
is the next one that's taken you know
replaced by these new movies so I kind
of feel like the Vincent Price version
is the only one that really did that
because that's kind of like at the end
like he realizes oh I'm the monster like
you guys see me as the monster and he
dies at the end yeah which I know
Charlton Heston dies of but they did
that jesusy thing and I wasn't really
into that but you know what I mean it
was a self-sacrifice thing through his
blood people would be washed clean of
the disease is what they're talking
about and he created it he created the
disease yeah so he was guilty he had to
die for it he was a weapon scientist but
Mega Man's really it's not like the book
but that's the best movie telling so far
yes man although you can say last man on
Earth of Vincent Price is the closest to
the book I Am Legend yeah bye-bye by far
it's a good movie I mean they still
changed some [__] but it's it's way
closer now I am Legend with Will Smith
it's a good movie but a lot of the
stories missing that would have been an
excellent movie had the vampire or the
mutants had they talked and had it been
the same moral lesson that he was the
monster all along that's they did that
wasn't in there so it was which is the
whole point of the [__] book yeah it
was really that's what made me mad it
was really dumbed down it was a shame
because you know Will Smith was still
[__] that was before he slapped the
[__] on stage so he was in good
standing
he delivered a good job he he delivered
a good uh performance in the movie yeah
he was just in it yeah he was good it's
just that man the script
there wasn't enough story there
because the vampires didn't talk
it would have been a lot better like I
said it was just kind of like a straight
up like post-apocalyptic monster movie
like it didn't really have any deeper
yeah that was the problem any interest
to it and there's a lot of those like
it's you know what I mean so I think
that's why it didn't really have that
extra yeah to it the book and the book
last man on Earth and Omega Man had a
deeper message
and it was missing in I Am Legend they
dumped it down to nothing it was just
dumped
um it's dumb that they took it out but
it's still an enjoyable monster movie
yeah it just wasn't really that it just
wasn't the original story right and it
wasn't that distinctive yeah I was gonna
say I like the Omega Man version because
the [__] the mutants were
psychopathic
[__]
Psychopathic albino mutants that saw
themselves basically they were kind of
kind of like Extinction rebellion and
antifa rolled into one
they were trying to destroy everything
that was old because it had brought down
the world they were against technology
they were against everything and they
saw they saw um
Neville who was played by Charlton
Heston as and he did bring it all down
but they saw him as a past an evil of
the past and he he had to be purged and
expunged from the earth he had to pay
for what he did he did eventually but
great flick great flick
um I like that telling of the story had
they put that in the [__] Will Smith
I think that I think the movie would
have been a lot more successful
because there have been more movie there
yeah so um okay so where was I yeah
witchfinder general which like I said
I've I've reviewed it or we reviewed it
together I can't really remember but it
wasn't that long ago
um also in the 60s he did some comedies
one of these was called Dr goldfoot and
the bikini machine I have not seen this
movie however I did see Brandon ten
old's breakdown of it and I kind of want
to see it now because it looks
cringy but also kind of hilarious like
in the way that the Austin Powers movies
were parodying except well it wasn't
serious because it was a comedy but and
there was like a sequel to that too like
with um it was called Dr goldfoot and
the girl girl bombs so
um yeah I might have to like do a double
feature on those one of these days yeah
I can't Camp guy got an Omega Master for
sale
yeah yeah I made the design yeah it's
good it's just right out of the movie
yeah so I'm missing one thing that I
wanted but we really couldn't do it I
wanted that MK 760 something handgun
that devil had I wanted that underneath
it but with the flashlight tied to it
that have been great
Camp guys talking about the book on the
beach a good book about nuclear
radiation approaching Australia after an
apocalyptic nuclear exchange man what a
great book though I read a book about
that I read that book yeah I did too I
read it it's cool and they were having
Death Races and [__] because they're all
gonna die anyway and they never
telephones Death Races where they were
all [__] wrecking their cars and [__]
didn't matter because only people only
had like four or five years to live
uh SPC says how do you all feel about
Soylent Green I think that I got it I
think of that movie every time I see
play at base meets yeah um it's good
yeah I don't like it as much as some of
the other kind of sci-fi ones from the
70s like Logan's Run and stuff it's slow
it's kind of slow yeah
um but
and the thing about it is that now that
you already know the big secret of it
yes so I like green is made from people
spoiler alert
um you know it doesn't have quite the
same impact
as it used to the thing is is that they
didn't pull that out of their ass they
were getting that out of a bunch of dab
malthusian writings from people like UN
based stuff and Club of Rome type [__]
where global warming and overpopulation
and they thought that there was going to
be a big population collapse and I think
they thought it was going to happen in
the 90s it never happened because
agriculture keeps getting better and
better technology
and um everything that was in that movie
is [__] that they were actually
entertaining euthanasia centers Canada's
got that now they made that illegal
illegal just a couple months ago
um
[__] uh artificial Foods you know soy
burgers and [__] remember when soy
burgers were new when I was a little kid
they freaked people out that there was
soybean mixed in with hamburger
they did they tasted terrible man the
texture was not good
uh they probably got it better now
because I'm sure it's just still out
there and I haven't tasted that taste in
a long time remember those cheap soybean
Burgers you get off of food trucks and
[__]
yeah and uh what else did they talking
about
just lots of global warming and uh
people living in apartments and the
apartment came with women that they
called them furniture and and massive
poverty and so it was just something
that they didn't pull it out of their
ass it was something that writings of
the time were word about
interesting movie but today a lot of it
would be kind of like old hat you know
like yeah okay
weird
um so yeah so also during the 60s uh
Vincent like I said did a lot of TV I
heard somewhere I don't know if it's
true or not but I heard somewhere that
he was on 900 episodes of Hollywood
Squares
and I remember watching Hollywood
Squares I don't really remember I mean I
remember Vincent Price being on there
sometimes but I don't remember him being
on there that much but I guess he was he
said he was on there like all the time
he was like a regular and he was even on
like the last one like the finale like
from 1980 which is crazy but yeah he was
all like during the 70s he was all on
that all that shit's on YouTube yeah all
those videos I was like yeah I need to
look that [__] up now because I was like
holy [__] maybe if I can get one with
him and Paul Lind yeah and Phyllis
Diller yeah that would be great
man you can even get Jokers Wild and
Liars club and all that [__] yeah
I don't know why I just I guess because
it had like the devil face yeah if
you're next Generation you grew up your
parents and [__] were watching that and
your babysitter was watching that [__]
you had to watch it
Price is Right
yeah my grandma has to watch something
let's make a deal yeah Monty Hall yeah
everybody with the weird costumes yeah
yeah yeah Santa Fe had like boiled eggs
in their purse or whatever then later on
Family Feud with all [__] Richard
Dawson's [__] creepy ass yeah like
[__] sexually assaulting everything
young women
and you could tell he was loaded he
would be he'd be drinking on the [__]
talk show
you could tell he was loaded yeah
but yeah so um but yeah he was on a ton
of uh of other shows after a Man from
Uncle uh get smart like I said the Red
Skelton Show he was on there once with
Boris Karloff
um and as I mentioned he also was a
Batman villain uh called Egghead he was
on there it was like it wasn't on there
like every week but he was it was like a
regular like recurring role
um and he also did like a lot of radio
during this time period because I kind
of feel like after the 60s he said that
and I'm paraphrasing but he was saying
that after a time because the 60s and
the 70s since that brought in
um you know more of
the kind of more like realistic style of
acting as opposed to like the more
stagey if you want to call it that like
style of acting so he was kind of trying
to Pivot more to doing
um you know more TV more stage work more
radio more stuff like that just because
in films you know they were looking for
more organic more naturalistic type of
acting style rather than the more
classical acting style that he was used
to doing so he basically just like
started pivoting and doing other things
like I said he always worked he
basically worked up until like a year or
two before he died even when he was like
very very sick and his daughter said
that too which like he was just always
always working because he just really
enjoyed it and to him that was
you know the definition of like not
uh you know not going into a slump is
like just always be working it doesn't
matter necessarily like what you're
working on but he would do like pretty
much anything
so yeah so he was in did all kind of
radio like for the BBC and stuff like
that as I mentioned earlier he did like
a Canadian Tv show uh called the
hilarious House of frightenstein which a
lot of people remember very fondly
um he was also in the Abominable Dr
fives in the early 1970s and the sequel
Dr five surprises again we haven't seen
it we're gonna see it we yeah I mean
yeah we saw the first one like a couple
years ago because Sophie was here and
that's like her favorite movie
um and theater of blood which came out
in 1973. now interestingly theater of
blood that's where Vincent met his uh
third wife Coral Brown
she was one of his victims in that and
he actually this is really the only
shitty thing that I ever heard about
like and I don't even know if it was
shitty because I wasn't there and it was
the situation but he did leave his
second wife well he did have he did
cheat on his second wife with coral
Brown
um and it was kind of like a big I don't
know it was a big Scandal but they did
kind of know about it and he did end up
like leaving his second wife to marry
the third wife but he was he was with
the third wife until she died I'm sure
there was a reason for it they weren't
getting old yeah yeah you know and
they've been married a while it wasn't
you know and it wasn't like oh they were
just married for a year and then he took
off with someone else they'd been
married for like 10 11 12 years
something like that so it wasn't you
know what I mean and and it was and it
wasn't like he ran off with like a
[__] 18 year old or anything like
that she was age-appropriate so so it
wasn't
so it wasn't anything like there that
was literally like the worst thing that
I thought I was like well if that's all
there is then 10 plus years though man
that's a long that's what I'm saying it
wasn't like he just yeah a lot of times
I think it was 11 years
that's the hand of the cycle we got
marriages that don't last that long
that's you know they got marriages Don't
Last Five Years A lot of them so you
know that just they just weren't getting
along
yeah
I mean I think that
um well I don't even want to say like
his daughter because okay so he has two
kids
um he has a son with his first wife
um whose name is Edith Barrett and he
had a daughter with his second wife Mary
Grant and I think the daughter was a
little bit mad because
um you know she was like oh well you
know he left arm up like my mom you know
for this other woman that he met on the
thing but she um I don't know she got
over and the thing about it was that she
honestly other than that she had nothing
but praise for him she said he was a
great dad he was very very involved like
he used to take her fish in all the time
and she has like a lot of really fond
memories of him and
um and she said he just adored his
children and like he just loved to spend
time with them so again like he just
seems like a wonderful human being
um thank you very much subjective a
critical hit I live though yeah thank
you very much thank you thanks those
flash bulbs flat flashlight yeah
um so yeah uh so let's get into a little
bit because so like I said um you know
he did continue doing stuff like
throughout the 70s we mentioned earlier
like he worked with Alice Cooper he
worked with deep purple obviously he did
Michael Jackson's Thriller in the 80s
and 1977 he actually started touring
with a one-man show like on stage
because he started getting back into
doing stage acting you know a lot of
actors like to do stage rather than
movies which I can understand and it was
massively massively successful and
probably one of his favorite roles and
everybody that knew him that saw it said
that that was his best role like it it
showed
um like his emotional range you know
what I mean this play that he did about
uh Oscar Wilde but it was like a huge
success so he did that in the late 1970s
but like I said he continued to do TV
through that he was like he made like
guest appearance he was on like The
Brady Bunch and [__] like that too so he
would do all kind of stuff oh and he
also hosted you remember that show that
was on PBS mystery and had the Edward
gory animation like at the beginning
like he hosted that for a long time too
man I should do some I should watch
those I remember those used to put me
asleep when I was a kid I'd probably
like him now though yeah I mean I
remember really liking them well because
I mean when I was a kid anything that
had anything to do with Vincent Price
and Edward gory I was all on board with
that because I was just watching I still
love I still love all of it I was
watching PBS so I could see Doctor Who
Tom Baker well yeah that was [__]
Justin Wilson in The Cooking Cajun oh
man I love that too yeah yeah well I
liked all the painting shows too I liked
all the painting shirts here like I like
Ross and I liked all the um all the ones
they had like aimed toward younger kids
that were like um like book reviews and
stuff like uh John Robbins I think his
name was like book bird and yeah he did
all because of where he would like draw
scenes from the books and [__] like that
so yeah I thought that was kind of cool
but so you can cook yeah I remember that
one yeah yeah you can cook is that dude
Martin Yan is he still around but I know
he couldn't be I mean it'd be 90 by now
bro probably well he wasn't that old
back then
I don't know I'm just but I don't know
man but I was young then but okay so I
feel like Vincent Price even though like
a lot of people had seen him like in the
movies from the 50s and 60s and stuff
like that I feel like him doing Thriller
and
um really helped to kind of endear him
to a new generation and also obviously
uh Tim Burton was a big fan and he
actually made in 1982 he made a short
film called Vincent which is like a
short animated film about a little boy
um who wants to be Vincent Price you
know what I mean and he actually like
when Tim Burton was really young he
actually got Vincent Price to like do
the voiceover for it and it's just like
a short film it's like six minutes or
something like that
um but Vincent Price thought that was
the coolest [__] thing ever
and that it was like better than any
he's like it's better than any star in
Hollywood Boulevard or you know the Walk
of Fame or anything like that he thought
that was so cool that somebody was like
homaging him like that and so obviously
when Tim Burton made Edward Scissorhands
in 1990 um you know he kind of repaid
the favor and he showed up as the
inventor like in that and that was
really his last I don't think it was the
last movie that he was in but it was
still like his last big significant role
he was also in the whales uh the whales
of August right in 1987.
um so yeah so there was that
and then so let's talk a little bit
about
um some of the other kind of stuff
because like I said we've talked kind of
about his career and stuff like that so
let's kind of talk about some of the
other [__] that he did because everybody
knows about all of the acting and the
movies and stuff that he did but all of
this other stuff they did on the outside
maybe sometimes they don't know about
so
um pretty much from the time he was a
kid
uh Vincent Price was super super into
art
there's a famous story about him that
when he was 12 years old
uh you know how some kids when they're
12 years old it's like they save up
their money so they can buy like a I
don't know what were they buying back
then in the [__] 30s or 40s bubblegum
a soap box racer or some [__] like that
or a hula hoop I don't know but um yeah
that was gonna say but that's the only
thing I could think of
um but he was actually saving up his
money so he could buy
um like a Rembrandt drawing
he wanted that so bad and he saved up it
cost 37.50 like in back then money and
it took him so he bought it like on an
installment plan yeah like he paid a
little bit up front and then like he
paid it off every year because he wanted
it so badly and I was like that's pretty
awesome like a 12 year old kid like
that's what he wants more than anything
is a Rembrandt it wasn't a painting it
was like a yeah it was like a um it was
a lithograph or something like that
um I don't know what 37.50 is in today's
money it's like a rip-off to me I mean
no I mean it was probably like it's
probably like a lot of money yeah but um
but yeah printing technology back then
was probably pretty I don't know if it
was a lithograph it might have actually
been a sketch I can't remember but um
but yeah so all through his life like he
was really really interested in art and
he was very interested too in
in like making sure that people that
everyone had access to art that was like
very very important to him he was really
into modern art maybe one of the first
kind of high profile people that was
into that
um I was watching a documentary about
him and they were talking to Dennis
Hopper who was like a friend of his and
Dennis Hopper was like Vincent Price was
really one of the first guys he's like
modern art it was very very
you know you know Middle America and
[__] like that didn't really know
anything about it and he's like and I
think Vincent Price was really
instrumental in like bringing that to
the masses because prior to that it was
kind of seen as like this elitist type
of thing but Vincent Price um and his
daughter said this too he was very
populist he thought that everybody
should have access to this stuff that it
shouldn't just be like reserved for and
then which is pretty cool like coming
from somebody that came for money like
he did
but so it was very very important to him
that that everybody super so him and his
wife they had a massive massive art
collection
and he was actually in East L.A at some
point uh I think it was in the 50s
and he was really struck by a lot of the
students there because a lot of them are
very um low income like a lot of them
were kind of like you know children of
immigrants and things like that and he
wanted them to have the same access to
art that he had always had the privilege
of having so he donated a whole bunch of
his art collection and like a
significant amount of money I'm not sure
how much exactly but it was enough to
open the museum and keep it running for
a significant amount of time and as far
as I know the museum is still there and
it's like named after him uh and his
wife and I think that the art it's
actually expanded now I believe it's
seven Galleries and it has
um I believe about 9 000 pieces of Art
in it now
um on top of like the ones that he
donated originally
um which I think he donated 90 pieces
initially but he kept kind of um you
know uh doing it but it's like I said as
far as I know it's still there and uh
it's still running so I don't know if he
left a thing in his will or whatever but
yeah he he gave like a lot of money to
that so he also um he would do stuff
like um do like writing like uh writing
grants for you know low income and stuff
like that and he was real into
um I think I mentioned this earlier like
as in regards to the art thing but he
got into
doing some stuff with Sears the big
department store which you know is
mostly not around anymore
but for about 10 years
um Sears got the idea that like in their
I guess like in their houseware section
they were gonna essentially like open up
like a not a gal well sort of like a
gallery but they wanted like real actual
artwork like picassos and Rembrandts and
stuff like that but not you know like
more affordable pieces I guess like I
said like lithographs and things and
they wanted everyone to be able to just
buy them to like come into the
department store and buy them and
Vincent Price was like all on board with
this so they kind of like collaborate on
this for like a decade and Vincent Price
I even saw like some clips of
like little promo materials he'd done
for it where you could go into Sears and
you could buy and they had like a whole
Gallery in there and Vincent Price like
curated it like he picked out all the
stuff and you could go in there and you
could like legit buy like a Picasso like
a little Picasso drawing or something
like that for like an affordable amount
of money and like put it in your house
so that was like really important to him
that people be able to do that that it
was like accessible to everybody copies
of high Earth at Sears well they weren't
copies they were original they're
Originals yeah yeah
yeah but like I said they weren't you
know some of them were I mean obviously
they weren't like the [__] you know
million dollar paintings no no no no no
they were usually like like sketches or
like drawings or something like that but
they were still by the artists and they
were original you know what I mean but
they were just not stuff that was like
millions and millions of dollars okay I
didn't know they had anything like that
yeah yeah I thought just
but they weren't copies of a painting of
a sketch over and over again no okay no
but like I said he he picked all the
stuff out like Vincent Price I picked
all this stuff out all right also
um I guess like in the White House
Collection there are several paintings
that were done by like Native American
uh painters and Vincent Price was the
one that kind of facilitated that like
through Sears as well because that was
another thing he was really into
um like Native American issues and
particularly like their Arts
uh and stuff and he was actually for a
time he was the head of the government's
um Indian like arts and crafts committee
so like he ran a couple museums and
stuff like that which is like Native
American art and everything so that was
another one of his
um one of his uh causes that he worked
for so I thought that was like really
cool as well but yeah that whole serious
thing is like super funny to me that he
just said that he just had like
worked at Sears and you could just like
go buy so I mean and they did it for
like 10 years like up until 1971. is it
time for commercials
um yeah I guess let's run some
commercials all right we'll be back in a
minute all right hold on just a second
we're gonna run some commercials and
then I'll be right back in a minute
oh
really
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
but yeah so aside from uh all the art
collecting like I said which was
probably he was actually on
um he lectured on art history as well
um and he used to show up on that quiz
show
um what's it called the 64 000 questions
he was on there all the time and they
would always ask him like art history
questions and he always like [__]
mopped the floor with that [__] yeah but
um well he kind of got here's another
thing that they mentioned on because
remember at the beginning of the show I
said that I watched the Mysteries and
Scandals show with AJ benza and it was
about Vincent Price and I was like what
could they possibly what dirt could they
possibly have offensive price he just
sounds like a lovely man and one of the
things they talked about and like I said
this is a reach is that because he had
showed up on the 64 000 question or
whatever that show was called
um and always answered the questions
right because they asked him about art
history and so he'd like win all this
money to give to charity or whatever
um you know when there was that whole um
Scandal they made that movie quiz show
about it where you know people came
forward and they had like a whole
Congressional committee about like how
people were like feeding people the
answers and all this other kind of stuff
it wasn't 64 000 question but I think it
was the show 21 that was mainly the one
but I think like a lot of the quiz shows
kind of got under Fire at this time and
I think that Vincent Price actually did
have to go and like give testimony that
like they hadn't fed him the answers or
whatever because that was kind of a big
deal but I was like that's not really a
scandal though I mean it was but it
Vincent Price wasn't like directly
involved he had just happened to be on
one of the quiz shows that they were
asking about you know what I mean that's
what I mean with that show when they
they were saying it was kind of like a
reach they were just like talking about
scandals that happened over here and
then Vincent was like oh I was kind of
in that for like five minutes but it's
like it wasn't really that big a deal
you know what I mean so there was that
so he would be like on that uh panel
show all the time and he was always like
answering the questions right
and as I mentioned earlier too
uh always known as kind of the OG foodie
I kind of feel like
um he was one of those guys and he
wasn't one of those dudes that was um
kind of like a food snob or anything
like he wasn't like that like he really
really liked fancy ass food but he also
liked like really humbled like down-home
kind of food too because it's good yeah
like he was real into like hot dogs and
[__] like that right right so um him and
his second wife Mary
um they put out like a bunch of
cookbooks I think they put out like five
or six cookbooks or something like that
like sometimes they would curate and
they would um like collect all the
recipes like from around the United
States like recipes that they had liked
and he would be on cooking shows all the
time and
um he was very famously on Johnny Carson
one time and showed them how to poach a
fish in a dishwasher so there was that
which I guess you can do that I mean
would you want I wouldn't advise it well
I mean yeah I mean just because you can
yeah that's all I mean you should we're
digging I saw like a little bit of that
clip because um I saw it on YouTube and
it's kind of funny because like they're
you know him like Johnny Carson and
Vincent Price are they were like kind of
you know cooking he's getting stuff
together and he has like a big bottle of
olive oil and Johnny Carson's like oh I
gotta check if this is fresh and just
like chugs it and then I love that
Vincent Price is like he just takes it
and chugs it too and he's like oh yeah
it's very good now it's like nice I like
that he just kind of like rolled with it
it was like really really fun whatever
Carson did back then you had to roll
away he ran Hollywood
I mean it was just yeah they seemed like
they were having a really good he could
make or break your career [__] they
were having a really good time but yeah
so like I said I think some of the um
cookbooks did go out of print you can
still find some of them some like at
used bookstores and stuff because I know
some people that have some
um but I think that they did
um kind of compile
some of the more famous recipes and
stuff like that into one big like
treasury like coffee table type book
like I think his daughter was
instrumental in doing that and I think
that came out in 2015 if I'm not
mistaken so you can still like get a new
one of it but if you like look and use
bookstores or something you can still
kind of find the old one sometimes those
you all who are too young to know this
Johnny Carson was the [__] the
original
Hollywood gangster okay he ran a [__]
night show a nighttime talk show and I
was young enough I'm old enough when I
was a kid I used to watch it it was a
great show
it was something about it was relaxing
at the end of the night you everything
was Consolidated in [__]
it was Johnny Carson shutting down
America for the night so you could go to
sleep that's what it was like right
but man he could make or break you he
his [__] clout in Hollywood was he
was Rock Solid if you came on his show
as any kind of a comedian or singer and
he called you over to his [__]
after your act if he liked you people
just clapped and okay you're out of here
but if he called you over to sit down
with him you had him made
if he called if he called you over to
sit down yeah you knew your [__] was
tight
and you apologize he would have called
you to sit down next to him your careers
you just sealed the deal on your career
you were going to be a hit
and and that that's what it was like
people watch that every day people in
Hollywood watch that and when they saw
Carson call you down to come sit with
him you were gonna get a job big jobs
getting called over well he was like uh
I guess they'd call it a taste maker
yeah an influencer yeah he was an
influence the original influence the
original was [__] Johnny Carson and
he was a master man and then Ed McMahon
he just seemed just laugh all the time
his job was just a laugh yeah laugh yeah
yeah he would announce it too but yeah
he was announcer looks like he just
laughed at [__] yeah he just laughed at
the great Karnak does remember the great
car that was that was my favorite like
stick of his Carson would dress up he
puts a Swami he put this [__] thing
on and he put an envelopes up to his
head and give an answer and then open it
and find the question and that [__] was
[__] funny as [__] man you guys can
see him on YouTube if you're young go
look at [__] the great Karnak do you
a [__] laugh your ass Mr 88 said I
watched Carson and I'm younger than Tom
yeah I remember like I used to stay up
with my grandma and watch it yeah Camp
guy said my mother was so prudish she
thought Johnny Carson was off color yeah
imagine that wow I remember Merv Griffin
it was a daytime talk show host I liked
him too also he was the elevator killer
yeah
that was a little kid when does anybody
know what that's referring to yeah or is
it just me the jerk no man what's your
brain I have two brains that's right
yeah
Merv Griffin actually with that elevator
killer in that Merv Griffin was cool too
he was yeah
uh all right so let's talk a little bit
about Vincent's uh private life then so
as I said he was married three times
like I said it sounds like a lot but
it's not really because the marriages
were actually like pretty long you know
I mean
um he actually his first marriage he
married in 1938 and she was also an
actress he actually met her on uh you
know stage like in a theater company and
her name was Edith Barrett and um those
two were together for I think 10 years
and they had a son
Vincent Barrett price uh who is a
columnist and also a poet uh they so
they were married for 10 years they got
divorced in 1948 and then he married uh
Mary Grant who was actually a costume
designer and uh like I said I think they
were married for 11 years and they were
the ones that had the daughter Victoria
who is like I said the one that still
curates or curates her father's um
Legacy you know what I mean
um so after this point so 1973
he was like I said he was working on
theater of blood
which is a great movie if you haven't
seen it by the way um you know I think I
reviewed it not too long ago either I
reviewed it by myself or we reviewed it
together I can't remember
but on the set of that movie he met an
Australian actress named Coral Brown and
ended up leaving his second wife because
him and coral Brown started having an
affair
um so then he ended up leaving his
second wife and Mary and coral Brown and
they were actually married until
until their death until Coral Brown
actually died of cancer if breast cancer
I think she had in 1991 and then Vincent
Price died only a couple years later so
they were married for you know quite a
long time now the thing about it
here's something that Victoria said
his daughter that I thought was kind of
interesting
um another thing that they brought up on
the Mysteries and Scandals thing was
that Vincent Price was during the
McCarthy era in Hollywood was graylisted
and actually did not work for a year
um because of his liberal views
but they don't she doesn't talk a huge
amount about it but she says that after
a year like I don't know if he had to
sign some kind of loyalty oath or some
[__] like that
um because then he started getting work
again but he was actually unemployed for
a year because he wasn't blacklisted
blacklisted like some actors were but he
was graylisted because he was suspected
to be in a communist right basically
what you're saying right he wasn't I
guarantee he would no I mean he was uh
liberal for sure and I'm gonna say that
he was actually one of the earliest I
don't know about earliest but he was a
very early advocate for
um you know lgbtq
um so I thought that was like pretty
cool too he actually came out of the 70s
against Anita Bryant that's a [__] we
should do a show about uh who was on a
anti-gay tear in the 70s and he came out
publicly and denounced her and he's like
stop being like such a shitty [__]
Nobody Business it's nobody's business
that's what I mean so so he was actually
like kind of ahead of the game on that
and the thing about it too
is that um his daughter Victoria
uh is gay now when she came out to him
she says that he told her like she said
he was totally like
okay like he was totally supportive
about it so he was very very uh you know
Progressive in that regard and he said
to her
that
um that he had had relationships with
men too so it's pretty much I feel like
it's kind of accepted knowledge nowadays
that Vincent Price was bisexual
um
at least according to his a lot of them
were yeah like so they're in the theater
man a lot of those dudes right right I
don't think that was actually confirmed
until fairly recently but I think it had
kind of been like rumored for a long
time that he maybe he was bisexual but
yeah and there's his daughter confirmed
it there's also a misconception that all
the LGBT kind of
movements and writes that it's new it's
not that she goes way back that was
going on in the 1700s in France and
Europe United States and everything
there were there were many sexual
revolutions it's just that it tightened
up in the 50s and it but it was I think
there was mostly uh the uh the official
line it tightened up only in the media
according to people that lived through
the 50s that I that I've heard
interviews with the 50s was wild too
just it was Underground there's bondage
going on
for his clubs there was all that kind of
stuff yeah you just had to keep it
waited just kept it under wraps I feel
like that that's kind of shit's always
going on yeah it's just it just depends
on how open you can be about it yeah
like now you can be open about
everything and nobody gives a [__] but
back then even in the 50s they were kind
of open about it but it had to be
sideways like a good example is
superheroes Wonder Woman Wonder Woman is
a was a bondage icon the dude that made
the Wonder Woman comic book was it was
into bondage
you know that's why she had the rope and
tied people up and everything and if you
looked at original Wonder Woman comic
books she's tying up other girls and
stuff this is a bondage comic book yeah
they they did they did the same [__] and
they didn't have
they would they didn't have male
pornography all right so what they would
do is they'd have men's fitness
magazines that were thinly failed
male pornography all right
so you still had plausible denial if you
bought it it's like look I'm just a
bodybuilder yeah yeah I'm not looking at
their glistening pecs yeah now some
dudes are just bodybuilders yeah but
this is well known you know me being I'm
in I'm into bodybuilding and male
fitness I'm not IBB Pro or anything like
that but [__] know the know the
greats you know
um
those dudes including Arnold evidently
you know it was possible deniability
they're photographs of them dudes out
there they did a lot of nudes they they
sold a lot of nude selfies and [__]
um they didn't have pornography was kind
of illegal but that was like a thing
that they could do on the side and of
course we know that women don't buy
pornography
they don't need to do that really it's
not even today I mean it's men women buy
erotica yeah but not pornography like
written erotica yeah Jenny's written
some yeah
um and the original
founder the the grandfather of
[__]
bodybuilding Eugene Sandow
but oh he was at least bisexual it had
been his wife [__] wanted nothing to
do with him because something had he was
giving [__]
private shows
for gentlemen
all his muscles and [__] and you know
when you go to [__] Olympia you get
the Sandow Trophy and there's [__]
Eugene with his [__] little
stepdaughter in his sphere and [__]
it was about men's physique you know
what a good looking man what a good
looking strong man should look like
well and then the first Dude that
[__] came up with Eugene he went to
Roman and Greek statues and measured the
proportions and says I'm gonna look like
that and this is the standard and people
didn't think it was possible but he
proved that you could look like that
gay men are going to be the ones that'll
be first on the [__] male
aesthetic [__] kick that's just and
then it's influencing straight guys
straight guys are saying it and going
okay yeah yeah that you should look like
that you know because they were right
it's better to look like that than to be
skinnier overweight or out of shape it's
better to look like a Greek statue
so it was always around it's just that
like she had said plausible deniability
yeah and dual purpose
what's that noise nothing okay is it
Pokey yeah okay yeah I didn't know if
something was the matter because I kept
hearing like a noise like she was
choking or something so it was just kind
of Dual Purpose stuff and plausible
deniability
but it was going on well I mean remember
in the 50s when there was like the whole
scandal with Betty Page yeah and like
the pictures of her which are very very
light bondage I mean no one would even
blink an eye at that [__] nowadays but
back then you had to like sell that
under the counter like you wanted the
hardcore [__] you know yeah even though
she got in trouble for that bondage was
bondage photos were was a way around not
showing sex because you couldn't do that
right you could show bondage though yeah
not quite as
but this [__] goes back
in modern era you know even 20s you know
you listen to Listen to uh interviews of
Louise Brooks this cute little actress
who uh was from the United States and uh
ended up going to Germany and stuff and
she would just
say that most of the time our handlers
were trying to keep an eye on her
because they were afraid she was going
to end up in the lesbian clubs and they
had lesbian clubs and [__] it was a big
rage in the 20s people forget
there was a big sexual revolution of the
1920s
yeah there's one every
so so many decades it's a cycle
it's not linear
yeah
um but yeah so like I said Victoria
um his daughter did come out in 2015 uh
and confirm what a lot of people had
suspected that Vincent Price was
probably bisexual Liz it seems like he
was mostly in straight relationships but
because he was married three times but
he apparently did have some
relationships with men he just followed
his heart yeah that's yeah but like I
said a lot of people have thought that
yeah prior to that but you know but it
was probably a lot more common than he
was just kind of the one that said about
it now this was another thing that she
said in the biography that I thought was
he was just honest about it yeah yeah
this is another thing and well like I
said after his daughter came out
um as a lesbian he actually joined uh P
flag he was actually like a honor he was
an honorary board member of P flag so I
thought that was kind of cool and he and
he was actually one of the first
celebrities I don't think he was the
first but one of the first celebrities
to come out and do um PSAs like telling
people not to freak out about AIDS you
know yeah like in the 80s so that I
thought that was kind of cool too well
they were trying to get people to freak
out about AIDS on purpose they were
trying to yeah but he but he came out
and said like yeah hey it's you know
chill out
so he was like one of the first
celebrities there's so many rumors man
yeah I remember that you could get AIDS
by looking at somebody for too long
you're just all kinds of [__] we were
scared of that [__] yeah crazy I mean we
were scared of a lot of things in the
80s
getting nuked it was always it was
terrible it wasn't terrible but you know
there was a lot of [__] like that
getting kidnapped stranger danger yeah
that kind of [__] too
um even though even though your parents
would just let you run around loose but
they were so worried you were gonna get
kidnapped
um but yeah so one thing that she said
in the book that I thought was kind of
interesting that when Vincent was very
very young
she said that you know because their
family was very wealthy and you know to
a large extent very conservative
um he didn't really question his beliefs
and kind of voted the same way that they
voted and when he was very young prior
to World War II I'm going to add he went
to Germany and Austria and was kind of
like hey this Hitler dude he's maybe got
some good ideas maybe he maybe he's
gonna bring Germany back you know what I
mean we've been surprised like he was
saying like he was very young there like
he was just well it wasn't just him he
was [__] Time magazine's Man of the
Year that's what I'm saying so it wasn't
like super super crazy yeah
well and the thing about yeah this is
prior to World War II this was after you
know obviously like after that came out
everybody was like uh yeah no that's not
such a good idea but um but yeah and you
know they she said too that it's like
their family not [__] on their
family but you know they were a very
wealthy very isolated
um very white very Protestant she's like
so they were like kind of anti-catholic
kind of anti-j wish
um you know so it was that and Vincent
kind of had those views too because he
didn't really question them like in his
youth but the older he got and like the
more he associated with other kinds of
people they said particularly him
hanging out with um you know like
Lillian Hellman Dorothy Parker like
people like that
um he kind of he said that he kind of
came to his senses and you know which
like left all that behind and she said
that um that was the one thing that
he felt the worst about in his life that
he had ever had any um that he had ever
had any idea in that direction that like
Hitler would ever be any good and it's
like he just felt bad about like that
his whole entire life a lot of people
thought that though before I know but I
can see how he would have felt really
bad about it because he seemed like a
nice person when that dude first
appeared a lot of people thought that he
was uh gonna solve a lot of problems you
know and we're not talking about
anything about the Jews or anything
we're just
charity was [__] falling apart look
like he was saved in Germany and then he
was going to save Europe from itself
basically but that's not how it played
out
attack in Russia was a big [__]
mistake and the final solution was a big
[__] mistake the problem with the
knots is the Dodgers only had one
problem they were [__] real racist
they just painted everybody
it kind of painted everybody with the
same brush you know what I mean uh just
they're like well all of these they were
they generalized all these people are
our enemies so we gotta get rid of them
it's [__] no that's not the way we
were looking at things because they
thought the Jews were a monolithic
structure that they were all against
them no
in the early days before a lot of the
Jews understood exactly what was going
on you had Jewish people trying to join
the uh that party
uh they were patriotic and they wanted
to save Germany too and they wouldn't
let them in you know
because they didn't you know the Jews
didn't know well I mean and I think the
Germans didn't know too they were
forming their ideas it just
they were a bad influence on each other
it's easy to whip each other they
whipped each other into a frenzy it's
easy to pick on a group that's not like
you and demonize them and use that to
manipulate people to your own views
because it's like oh well they're
they're the other you know we don't need
to give a [__] about Ben well I don't
want to get it get into it too much but
a lot of it had to do with what was
happening in Russia
oh and and the [__] Bolsheviks they
were afraid of both the rise of
Communism and the Bolsheviks but when
you looked at what was happening in
Germany Nazism was just a German
interpretation of Marx it was just an it
was German communism just it was
communism with what they call communism
with German Germanic characteristics
that'd be a good description of it and
then they had an alliance with the
Soviet Union and then they broke the
alliance and attacked the Soviet Union
during Operation Barbarossa it was a
blood feud between two competing
factions of lunatics really
Mr 88 says ironically when Schindler's
List was presented ad free on syndicated
television it was sponsored by Ford
Motors well maybe they felt bad I mean
Henry Ford's been dead a long time yeah
you know what I mean uh Tammy says yeah
she makes the point she says times
person of the year doesn't mean they're
a good person just that they had an
impact that year yeah they're not
they're not advocating that person's
views they're just saying this is the
person that made the move that had the
most influence in the early years though
a lot of people here liked him there was
there was yeah I know Fritz Kuhn and
Fritz Kuhn and like a large section of
the American German uh uh population the
German Americans were were behind that
they were in the boons uh there's a lot
of [__] was going on that uh
the there were people that didn't want
to fight him uh after Pearl Harbor it's
it's not as cut and dried as
modern history wants you to think
um
no there were a lot there was a lot of
sympathies for them
back in those days it wasn't until they
found those camps that's when [__]
people was oh okay yeah they're bad
because that's difficult to deny that
you know what I mean when they found
those death camps that was like yeah
okay I guess they are bad guys yeah yeah
but yeah so uh so Vincent Price it
seemed like he kind of got sucked into
it for a brief time but I mean even by
the end of the 1930s he was like yeah
[__] them and that was actually another
one of the reasons why he got gray
listed like during the McCarthy era was
because they called him a quote unquote
premature anti-nazi yeah you're an
anti-nazi but which is good but earlier
than usual so that's not good which okay
but yeah that was one of the reasons
they relisted him
um but yeah so like I said he seemed to
have snapped out of it like pretty young
which is good
um and even like in 1950 when he was
doing the radio show the saint
um very famously he kind of called out
uh against like racial and religious
Prejudice and one of the points that he
made on there which I thought was kind
of interesting was that he said you know
if
um we're divided by racial lines or
religious lines or something like that
that just like makes us weaker as a
nation which is what our enemies want so
he kind of like uh got into that a
little bit as well but yeah so like I
said also a member of P flag and uh you
know campaigned against Anita Bryant in
the 1970s which like I said it might be
interesting to do a show about her
because she was
kind of a [__] show she was kind of a
horrible person whether she was like a
um
didn't her family didn't they make
orange juice I kind of feel like she was
like an orange juice heiress and then
she was a singer but then she came out
and for some reason the hill she decided
to die on was let's all hate gay people
and like she came even for religious
reasons so she kind of came out against
that so yeah so Vincent Price like
denounced her which I thought was kind
of cool but yeah so um
so as I said Vincent Price lifelong
smoker which you know not a lot of
people were back then because I guess
they didn't realize
uh how bad it was for you but so he had
COPD
um you know chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease as they call it and um
also in starting I believe in the 80s he
started developing Parkinson's disease
also so if you see um Edward
Scissorhands which came out in 1990
um he's clearly
uh not in great health on that and and
like I said he was supposed to have a
larger role in that but because his
health was so bad that I mean he's
basically just in two scenes so that was
like his last movie
um but yeah so he was getting sick a
long time and like I said his family
were they talked about how um frustrated
he was that his body was just like
breaking down and he couldn't do like
all the cool [__] you know they said
because he had such uh you know such a
vibrant like love of life that he it
just made him mad that his body was just
like breaking down and he couldn't do
what he used to do anymore and it just
like made him really frustrated and so
he would just be always like you know
don't get old you know what I mean which
I mean and he lived a long time like
despite having been a smoker and
everything like that he lived until he
was 82 so you know that's that's not bad
um but yeah so he died in 1993 only a
few years a few years a few days before
Halloween and uh he was actually
cremated so and they scattered his ashes
off uh Nicholas Canyon beach in Malibu
as he requested
um the show that I watched earlier with
the couple that went to all these sites
around St Louis like they and they went
to Vincent Price's
um parents house and they also went to
the cemetery there in St Louis where his
parents are buried his parents and his
grandmother but obviously like Vincent
Price is not buried there because he was
cremated so you know what I mean
um so yeah and so I kind of feel like
again just like when we talk about we
did a show about Bella go see and Boris
Karloff we did a show about Christopher
Lee and Peter Cushing and I kind of feel
like when you do horror you kind of like
transcend generation and Vincent Price
is another example of that I kind of
feel like Vincent Price is always cool
it's not kind of like where you know
there's younger people now it's like oh
that shit's dumb or it's like that's old
or whatever it's just like new
generations constantly ReDiscover the
old [__] like Vincent Price Boris
Karloff all that and it's just always
cool and that's I kind of feel like you
don't really see that in a lot of other
genres like I could be wrong but you
don't really see a lot you don't see
like a huge
you know subculture of people watching
like
comedies from the 1930s like some of
them are still funny you know I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying you
don't get like
the Rabid fandom the way that you do
around like horror icons and you don't
see the same kind of like generational
um just longevity that you see
from these particular like horror actors
and actresses and stuff like that you
know you see kids now that are into
Vincent Price movies that are into Boris
Karloff that are in it and it's that's
crazy to me like you don't really see
that in a lot of other media and that's
just I don't know it's just like really
interesting to me like how that happens
and I don't know if it's just because
horror is just like that particular kind
of genre where
if you're into it you just want all the
horror you can get you don't care like
where it comes from I saw a quote
earlier I can't remember who said it but
um they said maybe it's because horror
as a genre is already dated in the sense
that
I mean I guess he was talking about in
the sense that it's like you know it has
its roots so much in like Gothic old
Gothic castles and [__] like that which
are centuries old so maybe this says
that it's like already old so it never
dates maybe that's part of it but I'm
not really sure I don't I don't know I I
just don't know why it happens like that
I mean I'm glad it happens but
you can't really
I don't know I I kind of feel like it it
would be hard to have a career like
Vincent Price had and still be
remembered
you know 20 years after he died he died
20 years ago and he worked almost all
all the way up until his death and
people are still watching his movies and
still talking about his movies it's hard
to believe that he died 20 years ago
because yeah I think he would have died
even long ago than that because he was
old he was like he was born in 1911.
yeah oh you would think that he would
have died 40 years ago but he lived a
long time he did and like I said he's
and everybody that
um that I watched on the documentaries
that knew him and everything like that
were like he seemed like he he just was
the quintessential example of a life
well lived like he just got so much out
of life and he seemed like he just did
everything he wanted to do I mean I'm
sure he didn't I'm sure he wanted to do
other things because I think his
daughter said oh he was kind of hoping
that when he got older
um you know he'd be able to travel more
and things like that but because he was
so sick
um you know he couldn't do it as much as
he wanted which you know was another
thing that kind of frustrated him but I
mean his legacy is still enduring like
nowadays and that's I mean you know what
other actors can say that like 20 years
after they're dead 30 years after
they're dead or somebody like you know
Boris Karloff or something like that who
died like a really long time ago too and
it's like people are still watching
those movies and like talking about
those movies and I just I don't know I
think that's really cool
you know I think that's really cool uh
Victor says 30 years ago so Boris
Karloff I guess 30 years ago something
like that yeah
Tammy says famous Betty Davis quote was
old age ain't no place for sissies yeah
he's true
uh Jeffy art said I believe one of Anita
Bryant's granddaughters came out to her
and it didn't go well yeah I can imagine
now I'm kind of I need to write that
down I needed to show about that [__]
because I remember hearing about her
wasn't she like an orange she's an
orange juice heiress right I've never
heard of her yeah yeah she was kind of
famous like in the 70s yeah but um yeah
it was it was kind of a big thing I I
don't want to know she was I don't want
to say she was like kind of in the whole
satanic Panic thing because she kind of
predated that but
that attitude was kind of like led to
satanic Panic you know what I mean and
she was like very specifically like
super super anti-gay so there was that
too but that is those that this this era
was an era of radio and television and
movies and that was the only mediums
that were out there no internet
so you had
people that had undue influence
if these people were coming up now they
wouldn't you would never know of them
yeah you wouldn't hear about it well
because everything is just so spread out
now yeah which in a way is shitty but in
a way is better yeah like I can't decide
if I like it better it's better because
everything is democratized yeah you're
not like you can just find whatever you
want like you don't have to like put up
with a bunch of [__] you're not
channeled you're not a captive audience
channeled down these corporate [__]
television channels you only had like
four of them back when we were kids and
they were basically telling you what to
believe through that thing
it was a means of control and they knew
it was it was propaganda
now it's real hard to propagandize the
public I mean look at them now man the
[__] corporate
news channels and [__] Hollywood
they're they're losing their [__]
because they don't have the traction
that they used to have
the means of production is available to
many many more people now like I said
you can shoot a [__] movie on your
phone yeah so which is great I mean
that's fantastic Americans are kind of
raised to believe that we have freedom
of press so that we never really had any
of that
basically
all your pretty much most of your
especially news channels
and Hollywood after World War II ended
up becoming mercenary forces for the
[__] federal government they had they
would pay them to
put out certain messages and that went
on for a long time and it definitely
happens now you know they're all just
kind of merged in with the government
the military-industrial complex and the
Congressional complex it's all just one
thing but the Advent of the internet
just broke the back of all that you know
and now the ruling class can't put out
orders to anybody and they can't keep
blinders on you you can now if you're
wise and you're paying a lot of
attention you can tell who's lying to
you and who isn't you know
and uh they're losing their [__] the
rich people are because they they ran
this system for [__]
hundreds of years
but it really got bad [__] but World
War II that's that's where the United
States got kind of went wrong
I mean the thing about it
is that the only thing is that you know
back in the old days like you know you
only had so many channels so everybody
would see the same [__] so you'd like go
and like everybody could talk about the
same thing now it's kind of like and I'm
not complaining because I actually do
like it better nowadays but now like for
example like I go to work and they're
talking about like some
country singer or something that was on
TV like some sporting event or something
I have no [__] idea what they're
talking about and it's like and I'm sure
if I talked about [__] I like yeah they
would have no idea what I was because I
was talking about like horror movies the
other day because there was a guy there
who is really in horror movies but
everybody else oh I don't really like
horror movies and I'm just like okay
well
last time the last time last time I saw
television was probably a couple months
ago and went down to the Oasis that down
biker bar and all those old people in
there were watching television on the
big screen television and they were
and it was a television program that
showed YouTube clips and of people doing
crazy [__] like America's Funniest Home
Videos they had that they had a little
bit of sports ball and it had some other
[__] on and it television is dumber now
than it was when I was a kid that's how
dumb it is now the only things I watched
like TV TV is like if Gordon Ramsay has
a show I'm gonna watch that but I don't
I don't watch it on live TV I just watch
it on Hulu like this yeah and I can't
believe people still watch that
I don't know who's watching that [__]
but I mean I guess some people are dumb
you know TV was always dumb though yeah
it feels even dumber now
I don't know I think it was always dumb
in some ways I feel it's less dumb but
then in other ways it's more
no daytime talk show the daytime
programming is dumb Beyond dumb and it's
about the internet most of it
well yeah because they realize Well
everybody's looking at that so we might
as well Farm some content from there
it's like right right well because they
can't afford to like employ people to
like actually come up with original
content so they're just gonna like
[__] go scrape some [__] from that's
already been done yeah it's pitiful I
don't think television's gonna last much
longer it's not the source of the
entertainment it's commenting on the
source of entertainment which is the
internet that you know it's over then
Jeffy Hart says I feel horror content is
a great window window into the era it's
produced but in a way that's insightful
that's actually like a really
um that's a really good comment because
the thing about horror is that it always
it always kind of like
um codifies I feel like and expresses
the anxieties of whatever era that it
comes out in and in that way I think
it's like the most it's probably the
most instructive genre to watch from any
era because you can always see what the
overriding concerns of most people of
that era were by watching the horror
movies not so much watching the other
stuff like sometimes you can glean some
stuff from the other
um genres as well but horror because
it's you know by its very nature it's
exploring you know darker issues like
the dark side of things and can go
places that other genres don't
um I feel like it's a really good
I don't know it's just it's just like a
really good way of um sussing out
whatever people were worried about in
any particular I mean you know and the
first thing I thought of I don't know
what I probably just thought of this
because I was watching some [__] the
other day but
um you know I mean look look at all the
like Eco horror for example they came
out in the 1970s and that came out as a
direct result of Silent Spring you know
that book that came out about like the
DDT DDT and like um you know all the
poisons and the water and everything and
so immediately like all these movies
come out about like oh we're poisoning
the water with Mercury and like these
fish are growing Giant and like now we
have mutated bears and giant bunny
rabbits and all this other kind of stuff
and I've you know the same thing kind of
happened with the big bug movies in the
1950s everyone was like worried about
radiation and all that kind of stuff
because they didn't really understand it
and so you know now we have giant
tarantulas and giant crickets and giant
this and that so it's just like really I
don't know it's just like really
interesting and now I'm kind of
interested to see like in 10 years 20
years it'd be interesting to look back
at the horror movies that came out
during this era
um to kind of see like what the
anxieties were
you know because I kind of feel like
horror movies are really the best
distillation of that
I don't know I kind of feel like the
horror movies in the last few years have
just been kind of all over the place but
in a way that a lot of the media is
because it's just
now it's just kind of tailored to
everyone else's like niches and
different subcultures and things so it's
not like
I don't think it's commenting on I don't
know like mainstream society as a whole
because I don't know if there is such a
thing anymore because everything has
been so fragmented and like I said that
sounds like a bad thing but I don't
think it's a bad thing
John I was saying that we both reviewed
theater of blood because Tom kept on
going about going on about Vincent
disguising himself as a gay guy that
that that yeah I remember this well
theater of blood was the one where he
like was The Shakespearean actor that
all the critics like [__] on him because
he was super hammy so he said [__] those
[__] I'm gonna kill them all and he
was gonna kill him in like really like
over the top ways it's a great movie
it's super fun I vaguely remember it
it's super fun I vaguely remember me
talking about it it turns out he's just
coming out he's not it's not a disguise
his straight his straight Persona was
disguised the game no I'm just kidding
but uh yeah yeah [__] price was the
[__] man he was good
it's like yeah and like the more I find
out about him it's just like like I said
Not only was he
just a great actor who was in like some
[__] classic movies but he also
seemed like a wonderful human being
which is always nice to find out I
didn't know there was a fives part two I
want to see that now yeah yeah because
yeah we've seen the first one I don't
think I've ever seen the second one now
that you think about it
I think some I think somebody mentioned
it before and on another show when when
somebody brought that up that that part
two was better
I don't know
maybe I think that's what he said that's
usually not the case because sometimes
it's true sometimes it's true
Mr 88 said our grandchildren will think
we were terrified about sand snow tree
and Mountain sharks with five heads
sharks don't forget Ouija sharks yeah
because there are a lot of shark horror
movies Zach says a lot of horror from
the last decade to me has been
existential like hereditary yeah I kind
of noticed that too like there's
definitely a vein there of that well
because like I said because nowadays
because the means of production has been
so democratized it's hard to really make
a statement about oh everybody in this
Society like I said back in the 70s it
was easy it's like Eco horror was like a
big thing everybody was worried about
big ants big rants well everybody was
worried about like environmental Horrors
oh my God we're poisoning our water
supply and [__] like that which we were
yeah so you know what I mean
um so I get that the people were like
worried about that but nowadays it's
because there's like little pockets of
people with different concerns like
working on stuff I don't know if it's
the same like overarching but it's still
like I don't know I still feel like it's
instructive to like watch it though
because it always
it's kind of like a a window into where
a collective psyche in our Collective
anxieties you know what I mean
uh Mr idiot said Santa Jaws overweight
North Pole sharks too I keep meaning to
watch that maybe we should do that for
the Christmas show because I keep seeing
it like coming up when I was I'm like
Santa Jaws that really sounds like
something I need to be watching but I
don't know if I want to or not we've
seen like enough shitty shark movies
don't watch Ouija shark by the way not
terrible it's terrible it's a great idea
it was a great idea it was just like we
want to see a great bad movie you see
velocaster it's a [__] it's a [__]
masterpiece
that is definitely the Citizen Kane of
bad movies yeah philosophy and I'm not
even being facetious that's what I'm
saying that it's a great movie it's
super fun it's a great movie yeah I
enjoyed it immensely I want to see it
again don't I have that I don't know if
you have it it's on well it was on 2B I
don't know if it's still on there
but it's been on 2B for like as long as
I can remember it it might still be on
there yeah
jeffreyard said YouTube is today what
broadcast was at the dawn of the
internet streaming services or what
cable and premium channels were yeah I
guess so yeah evidently the um
all the streaming services are going to
collapse it's all going to end up via
Netflix
that's what that's what I've been
hearing through like Midnight's Edge and
stuff because Disney is probably going
to back out of Disney plus a lot of
these little [__] CBS [__]
streaming services they just there's
just two [__] many of them man well I
kind of feel like they'll probably just
like have to conglomerate they have to
[__] well because yeah the thing
about it is that it's gonna be like well
when cable first started I remember
bitching because they'd always sell it
to you in packages right it's like well
you have to have these 100 channels or
whatever and it's like you know 85
percent of them you never watched
you know it's like I don't I don't need
[__] religious channels or ESPN I
don't watch any of that [__] but it all
came with the package yeah so I kind of
feel like it might go in that direction
again because now it's almost like the
opposite problem where it's just kind of
like there's 40 bajillion small
streaming streaming sort of like
everybody has their own streaming app
but it's like all the [__] you want
isn't on the same one so you have to
have all these little ones and like some
of them are cheap they're only like five
dollars a month but that adds up yeah I
mean I have how many streaming services
do we have we have Netflix we have red
box we have Amazon Prime with the Brit
box add-on
um I have shutter I have Hulu
um and I have HBO Max that came with my
phone plan actually and then there's
like free ones too like you have like 2B
and freebie and Pluto and stuff like
that where you can watch it for free
which is nice but I thought we paid for
one more
yeah I can't remember what it is though
well I mean I pay for HBO Max but like I
said that came up that came with my
phone plan HBO Max is good if you're
into like classic movies because they
have a [__] ton of like the classic
movies that everybody needs to see they
have like pretty much all of those I
don't know so much and they have like
good series and stuff too but like I
don't know so much about new stuff but
they're good for that so I like them for
that because I like watching a lot of
that but you know and the thing about it
too is that I really like having shutter
also but that's also super cheap I think
I only paid 59 for a year
you know
but 2B has a lot of good [__] too you
just gotta the problem with 2B
and I'm not gonna [__] too much because
it's free
their search engine blows yeah you can't
because look shutter
they have
collections it's like hey I want to
watch a giallo movie hey I want to watch
a Creature Feature like they have them
all categorized I still think shutter is
still one of the one of the [__]
coolest ones it is yeah yeah but 2B you
got shutter for five bucks didn't we
yeah it's like I said I pay 59 a year
yeah so which is nothing yeah
um and it's great they and they add new
movies new movies old movies like every
week they add like a handful
and they have like a good combo of like
old [__] and new [__] and foreign [__]
they have like everything oh my God damn
oh a poster fell down poster fell off
that falls down off them yeah but um the
thing about to be though is that they
have like a bajillion horror movies and
they have like a [__] ton of good ones
but there's no way they're not
categorized and they don't that you
can't like you can't search for them
like out like you can search for them
like if you know the title but they
can't like oh list them alphabetically
or list them according to you know what
I mean so it's really really good so you
have to sit there and scroll through
like thousands and thousands of movies
like looking for a good one because
they're not in any particular order
which is crazy I really wish they would
sort that out but like I said they're
free so I can't complain too much
uh mr88 said I only have Amazon and
Disney plus so I don't stream much I
feel that streaming is crazy dirt cheap
fabulous value my DVD collection costs
more than a nice brand new car yeah when
you think about it I mean even if you
have multiple streaming services like we
do it's not horribly expensive like I
said I pay for Amazon Prime you pay for
Netflix I pay for shutter I pay for Hulu
I think Hulu is like nine bucks or
something
um at HBO Max
my that comes with my phone plan my
phone plan 65 a month and it just comes
with that
so it's like really when you think about
it it's really not that expensive
because there's a [__] ton of movies on
there
I mean more than I could ever watch I
can it's so many that I can't decide you
know what I mean and I'm just sit there
scrolling through going I don't know I
don't know what I want to watch you know
what I mean there's too much [__] on
there there's well that's what I mean
it's like it we're kind of like spoiled
for choice now like back in the old days
it's like there was this one movie and
you wanted to see it it was like this
big deal but now it's just like we have
all the movies and it's like now I don't
even know what I want to watch I'm like
scrolling through there for two hours
and I can't think of anything and then I
just go to bed and some of the new
series you look at it and go like yeah I
don't want to see that it looks like
it's a good series but you're just like
you just don't care there's two [__]
many of them well the thing about it I'm
always like reluctant to start a series
because I'm like man what if I really
get into that and then you get away and
then I'm gonna be stuck for like five
seasons like you know what I mean yeah
it's like that's kind of so that's kind
of why I'm like hesitant to like start
new ones but because I have so much [__]
I have to watch still it's rumored that
the [__] they're finally
gonna do a good Conan series and it's by
the Robert E Howard [__]
um
what do they call it not the fund but
like trust or yeah yeah the guys and the
dude that's in charge of Robert E
Howard's [__] is a Robert E Howard
fanatic uh he pulled it out he pulled it
away from uh a couple of the services
because he says nope that's not Conan so
he just took it from him he doesn't care
about the money he took it away from uh
I think Google there's one of them they
were going to do it and I think that
Netflix was gonna do it
but they were gonna [__] it up they're
gonna basically make it like He-Man or
some [__] he's like no that's not what
we're talking about it's going to be
real Conan not [__] Conan evidently
somebody's picked it up and it's gonna
supposed to be real good
or the the the the the Robert E Howard
Association the the the trust fund or
whatever has has uh is is is has
approved what it is that uh what this uh
platform is going to do with it it's
going to be high end and it's going to
be kind of true to the books not so much
the Milius
Schwarzenegger Conan one
it's gonna have that in it that kind of
motif you know like somehow for Frank
Rosetta painting but it's going to be
like the books
can be good and the [__] comic books
uh
um the Marvel comic books from the 70s
and 80s be like that
yeah
there's a lot of [__] I didn't know
about that
in the original book you know Tulsa Doom
he was a sorcerer but he had a skull
head
and they were gonna make a [__] movie
about that but the original movie
[__] wasn't going to be uh what's his
name [__] um
he was gonna have a skull ahead well
they were going to make toys and
everything for the Conan one movie
once they saw that [__] and it was
[__] rated R they're like kids can't
see this We're Not Gonna sell these in
these toys the work that they were going
to do for Conan ended up becoming He-Man
that's why Skeletor has a [__] skull
head yeah because originally thulsa Doom
had a skull for a head I didn't know
that
yeah
He-Man was just Conan with blonde hair
it was the same
same thing
oh my God Mr 88 I just I just had a
flashback 80s cable was an endless
circle of Grease too yeah yeah the
pirate movie yeah Fraggle Rock I don't
remember yeah I remember you don't
remember Fraggle Rock remember the movie
no no it's not a movie it was a show
this is Jim Henson
big it was on HBO vaguely oh my God I
loved frag I also remembered [__] like
[__] Wembley in the terrible tunnel
adventures in the forbidden zone with a
young [__]
um uh what's a little redhead that was
from uh uh uh [__] Breakfast Club uh
Molly ring Marley ring wall remember
that remember uh space Hunter I think it
was called space hunter
in the forbidden zone I definitely
remember Greece too which I've seen so
many times that I've memorized it and
then the pirate movie Galaxy of Terror I
really liked the pirate movie time after
time they used to show that all the time
um
what was the one with uh uh [__] what
was the one with Chevy Chase and Goldie
Hawn
that was like a murder mystery the [__]
was the name of that thing uh I wanted
to like re-watch it no no no no that was
Tim Curry although they showed that a
lot too oh man we should review clue one
of these days too what the [__] was the
name of that movie Burgess Meredith was
in it too he had a python named Esme oh
man I don't think I saw it oh it was
good I mean I remember it being good
I'll remember in a minute
that was that wasn't a girl or a boy
movie it was just a movie movie
don't be weird I just remember what it
was what I was watching back then horror
movies action movies and uh yeah I
watched all that too yeah I watched
pretty much everything yeah if it had
titties and it was after 11 I'd be I was
gonna stand up and watch that remember
that yeah it's looking funny
it's just a different world back then
man
well it was hard to see titties but yeah
now it's like super easy to see titties
yeah it's you watch you were gonna watch
you almost like don't value the titties
because you can just see titties
whenever you want to yeah just go on
Instagram it's titties
titties everywhere I mean we're gonna
stay stand up and [__] get get the
[__] scared out of us for [__] Friday
the 13th Part Two because you can see
some titties in it that girl going out
going out to [__] skinny dip at night
remember that they're like yeah titties
yeah yeah she's gonna die too you know
just yeah it was a [__] weird time
you show your titties you get killed
that's how it happens in horror movies
the moral of [__] the moral of [__]
it's Friday the 13th is that if you have
sex you get killed oh yeah well that was
the moral of the story that was the
moral of a lot of Slash yeah well I
think that started that started that
started with Halloween yeah uh because
you know Jamie Lee Curtis was like the
virginal good girl and she was the final
girl she was yeah she yeah she lived
because she didn't have sex because the
thing about it was I mean there was
slashers prior to that like black
Christmas but black Christmas the final
girl in that she was not a virgin
because the whole one of the whole plot
points in that was that she was going to
have an abortion and her boyfriend was
mad Okay so
I feel like that started with Halloween
you know then there was then there was
the [__] Canadian
version of [__] Friday I think 13th
it didn't have any [__] killing or
blood in it [__] Terror train
remember that one yeah yeah Jamie Lee
Curtis yeah like she was in that one too
territory yeah okay because I like that
one too yeah it was like it was set on
New Year's Eve yeah we just reviewed
that not too long ago yeah if you
remember
yeah it wasn't scary at all no not
really it scared me when I was a kid but
it's not scary at all looking at it plus
David Copperfield was in it that's right
doing his [__] lame as magic magic
tricks kind of get trying to get laid
Yeah yeah that was super fun I had
forgotten he was in it and then we
watched it again I was like oh yeah I
forgot this [__] was in this
movie Mr 88 said yes uh Jen and I had
the same cable service because every
time she talks about cable movies I had
the exact same rotation right it's yeah
it was the same
um do you remember the small five by six
inch ish cable program catalog that came
each month yes I do remember that and it
was yeah like the little HBO it was like
that yeah yeah I remember that and you
would look it was like a little drink
menu it was a little bit well that's the
thing like I guess because it was early
days and they didn't have the rights to
like any big movies or anything like
that because it wasn't like now where it
was just like a pipeline where it shows
in the theater or whatever and then it
like would come to video like they
didn't even have [__] would come to
video but it would be like years later
so they kind of had to just show
kind of more obscure movies or movies
that were kind of like not all that
famous or something like that but they
showed but they showed the same ones
like over and over so that's how I ended
up seeing Greece too probably like 50
bajillion times because it was always on
yeah and the same thing with like Time
After Time like I said not complaining
because time after time is a [__]
awesome movie if you haven't seen it
came out in 1979 yeah but um I'm still
trying to think of it what the [__] was
the name of that what the [__] was the
name of that one with Chevy Chase and
Goldie on in it no no God damn it it was
like it was like a murder mystery
there was a lame-ass movie called
[__] doctor Detroit that I remember
that oh yeah yeah that was Dan Aykroyd
I remember that one
Mr 88 said they usually play the same
movie uh twice per day on three
different days each week yeah they would
because like I said they didn't have
that many so it's like they'd always
have so you turn it on but like oh hey
look the pirate movie's on again and
like I would sit there and watch it
again I didn't have anything else to do
you know what I mean
uh Jeffy art said young people will
never know the struggle of trying to
watch scrambled channels for boobs on
cable with their parents are out for
them [__] line going like that yeah
and you're like here wiggle Wiggly and
Danica it didn't work I think I saw a
nipple what really frustrates that for a
second to get real clear yeah oh there
it is I think whoever it was that was
like running that [__] was probably like
here let's give them a charge
because that's what I would do if I was
if I worked there give the teenage boys
what you were [__] stranded straining
to watch because that was porn but it
was censored porn
you had to go to VHS to see the real
thing
you had to go in the stinky sticky back
room through the curtain yeah the bead
curtain censored pouring all you do is
saw some dude's ass bounce it up and
down that's what they said to the girl's
face dude's ass the girl's face that's
it this is a big area yeah
yeah get out of the way man it was
they cut all the other Shots Out
yeah get out of the way
oh my God all right so I guess we're
gonna wrap it because it's 10 30 and I
really gotta go to bed yeah yeah so uh
because I gotta get up early in the
morning
to go to work but thankfully this
weekend is a three-day weekend so I'm
looking forward to that that should be
fun
we'll get to do the haunting Monday show
like and I'll actually have all day to
get ready for it which is nice okay
so yeah uh all right so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this show which was mostly
about Vincent Bryce other than all the
millions of sidetracks that we went off
on but you know what else is new Oscar
and Misty are watching this song oh are
they there yeah oh that's yeah look at
look at the weird colors yeah weird
colors yeah okay Misty you're on
we put Misty on Mr 88 says the first
Prime Time ass had to be Dennis Franz
why yeah I know right maybe they thought
if it was like too sexy and asked then
everybody would like call for more of
that so they didn't want people to like
have more man ass on TV so they're like
let's but Dennis Dennis friends is hairy
ass up on there then everybody be like
no more butt no more butts please no
more no more man butts let's just keep
it with the with the ladybutts
you know I don't know I'm getting Chuck
Norris videos sent to me but
it's like a little swell
yeah I figured it yeah as soon as you
said Chuck Norris videos I knew it was
sending them again
I know who sends you all the things yeah
all right so uh yeah hopefully you guys
enjoyed the show about mostly about
Vincent Price
um you know and this was a fun show to
do because I [__] love been surprised
like everybody who doesn't love Vincent
Price come on he's he's he
he's awesome all right so um the next
show obviously will be Friday night
which is the Sidetrack show so we'll
have some drinks and talk to you guys
about whatever [__] we feel like
talking about so like usual uh so yeah
so have a good rest of your evening you
guys have a good day tomorrow and we'll
see you guys again on Friday night good
night